à à
anh alo Chào con bằng Alo gọi nói này có
vẻ hơi to quá vậy mình đẹp Cái này hay
mình cảm thấy rất to to
ờ ờ chào các bạn
tranh thủ tâm sự một tí trước
anh check mail
bảo này bạn vừa gửi mail tâm sự tình cảm
gì đó thì phải
Ừ ok thì mình mình thử cái hôm nay không
biết tâm sự gì hôm qua hôm trước thì
muốn tâm sự đủ thứ hôm nay sẽ không biết
tâm sự gì mấy mày sao Mình chỉ nói qua
nhanh vậy cả giá
kệ bày thử ta cái Ngó mà mình chưa làm
ra khá nhiều nhóm kiểu tình cờ mình thấy
ở trên trang chủ bởi vì mình mình không
biết thì nói các bạn chưa là được là
trang chủ của mình mình không theo dõi
bạn bè mình bạn bè hôm trước hôm trước
của ông mới cưới tôi còn chẳng biết ông
đấy đã cưới rồi cơ kiểu thế gì à
Ừ tôi không theo dõi bất kỳ bạn bè nào
cả
các bạn bè đôi bạn bè đôi khi đăng những
cái thìa mình không quan tâm
Ê bà thậm chí ở thằng Facebook nó còn nó
còn thay đổi cơ chế thuật toán mà nó là
bạn bè bình luận hay thích cái gì đó nó
sẽ hiển thị lên trang chủ của mình thành
ra là có rất nhiều thứ mà bạn bè thích
mấy cái nhảm nhí tôi phải tình trạng cái
thăm
thằng bạn khá thân rồi ơi
hội thân từ hồi cấp 2 tôi chạm nó chỉ bị
nó chia sẻ mấy cái của em Plus chẳng hạn
khi anh cờ thế
Ừ Tôi Vẫn Nhớ cái lần mà hôm mà đi chơi
với nó xong vui vẻ xong sao đi về rồi
tôi bảo là có gì nhắn tin nói chuyện nốt
ruồi nó nói câu đó là ông dặn tôi rồi
còn đâu như kiểu thế
nghe đại khái thế nhưng mà tôi lại vô
tình thỉnh thoảng vẫn thấy được vài bài
đăng từ người khác mà chính xác là từ
những cái bạn nó hot girl mà tôi đang
theo dõi
Ừ tôi theo dõi mấy bạn hóa đơn thì Mục
Đích Ngắm phần cũng là để mà
em lấy ảnh mấy bạn đấy là đáng lên nữa
mà thấy có mấy bạn gái anh chia sẻ Đủ
thứ tiền hình à Mấy cái 22 cũng cũng
cũng hay cũng một sự giải trí giống như
cái bài này chẳng ạ Bạn ấy thì ra không
hài cái nhóm này công nhận đăng nhiều
cái hay liên quan đến công việc nhưng bà
này không mẹ mày Mình thấy khả là hai
lại cực tươi đây là nói lên tất cả đó là
ờ ờ
các bạn bạn này kiểu thư cá à Chẳng cần
mình mình không cần phải đọc dài dòng
tất cả đúng này thì ra là như tôi đã
từng nói mấy bạn đó là đừng bao giờ nghe
như kiểu của người giàu kể chuyện nó họ
đã thành công Từ từ ABC như thế nào các
bạn bắt chước thì đôi khi lại không được
đâu cũng như là bắt chước Ở đây có rất
nhiều yếu tố phải phải những nói chung
là rất nhiều yếu tố thì họ kiểu đi con
đường đấy mà nó ổn mẹ các bạn đừng phải
nghe lời khuyên hay nghe hiểu anh học
lập trình như thế nào để được như bây
giờ vẫn Vân không không mỗi người sẽ có
cách hợp khác nhau vân vân Nói chung ở
mình chỉ cần học đúc kết là người ta có
cái tư duy gì khi
người ta có cái tư duy gì khi mà khi mà
xử lý vấn đề khi mà cậu gặp khó khăn
nóng ạ và họ có cái kiểu mục tiêu ngay
từ lúc đầu họ đặt ra là gì mấy cái người
thành công ấy ngay từ đầu người ta không
nằm mục tiêu bé thôi chúng ta đặt mục
tiêu lớn mà Đó Ngoại rất nhiều người
thành công người ta đặt mục tiêu lớn chứ
không phải đặt mục tiêu bé tí là tự
nhiên thành công không có chuyện đấy
đúng ạ Thật ra hôm trước tôi còn đọc một
cái bài nữa Hai nữa
anh nghe tội không lưu đó là kiểu à
ờ ờ bài bài đấy Hãy tiêu đề bảo là chắc
phỏng vấn chắc ma các sự thứ ra tôi
không thích cái tiêu đề giật Tít kiểu
như thế bởi vì tôi còn chẳng biết là
thực sự ông ấy có nói có đấy không cũng
như là chắc chắn ăn thêm mắm thêm muối
vân vân được nghe người giàu kể chuyện
nó vẫn là chuyện người giàu đúng không ạ
nhưng mà ông ấy có cũng có nói việc là
kiểu
người nghèo là người
ở nhà là người không phải là người không
có tài sản mà người không thể làm ra
được tẩy sạch ví dụ sợ là ông trúng số
ông có vẻ Đang có triệu đô ông tay nhưng
thực ra ông không biết tạo ra thêm tiền
mỏng chỉ biết tiêu Thì đấy vẫn là người
nghèo có nhiều tiền còn nếu mà nếu mà
người mà đang không có tiền trong tay
nhưng mà họ có thể làm đây của tài sản
giống như các danh nhân hay các thứ thì
họ chẳng qua là họ chưa đến thời để họ
giàu nhưng mà họ sẽ giàu
Ừ thế thế nơi nào Thực ra tôi cũng có
một tí liên quan lễ hội trước tôi nói
với ông rồi cái chị tiến thủ theo kiểu
là đôi khi con gái họ sẽ chọn người mà
có thể giàu trước à Có thể đâu nha Chứ
biết rồi không Tôi bảo rồi cái đấy con
nhưng con nhiều yếu tố nhưng mà họ có
chí Tiến thủ họ có thể phấn đấu họ có
thể thành công chứ không phải họ đứa
hiểu quá khu nhà giàu Nhưng mà ăn chơi
phá chỗ ngồi kiểu chẳng biết làm gì cả
đúng ạ
Ừ thì đứa con gái yêu khi không thích
kiểu đấy nó thể thích theo kiểu thích
yêu hẹn hò kiểu đi chơi họ không bao giờ
thích cưới hồi đấy mối quan hệ lấy họ
cảm thấy à về tương lai về sau trừ khi
Giàu nó tiêu mãi không hết
à à
anh nói chung là vệ còn đúng rồi rồi
nhắc hơi quá Nhưng nói chung và về cái
bài này thì ra tội từng nói mấy ông về
cái quan điểm của tôi đó là tôi làm việc
ở trên công ty là rất là đài đinh lăng
mạ tôi mang tiếng ở dân gọi là dân đẹp
đúng không ạ
Từ nhỏ tôi làm từ a đến z nhưng quán cả
để hỗ trợ các thứ hướng hỗ trợ nhiều bên
Ừ nhưng mà tôi không vừa nói cái câu là
đấy không phải việc của em thứ thứ xếp
mà có nhựa xếp có bảo là cậu đang có khó
khăn gì thì thì tôi hỏi xong rồi tôi thử
mỹ cách giải quyết Cùng Sếp cứ nói chung
à Tôi chưa Rồi cái quan điểm đó là cái
không phải việc của mình thì thực ra nó
cũng hơi bị bốc đồng và cũng như là hơi
bị tộc mạch một tí hoặc mặt trời không
ăn thôi không là một đứa hay tò mò và
chuyện riêng người khác nhưng mà ông chỉ
đọc mạch ở đây làm chưa ạ việc gì cũng
như vậy bảo em nhảy vào để mà hỗ trợ
Em đã tắm rồi Đâu 8 giờ mới được học mà
Đúng không ông vào sớm thì cũng phải
chấp nhận ngồi nghe tôi tâm sự không
khi hạ trầm ông ấy không thích nghe tôi
sớm xong rồi Tôi ở xảy rất nhiều bình
luận gần gần đây í a
Em đừng như là bình luận ở những video
cũ cơ nhưng mà vẫn ở gần đây chẳng hiểu
sao mấy ông bảo là em không vào học đâu
em kiểu đang chán đời tự như em vào nghe
anh tâm sự để có lấy lại sự sợ ngay ngay
giờ đây luôn rồi kìa Em em đang buồn rồi
cậu nghe anh tâm sự dòng thoải mái các
thứ có bạn và chỉ thích mấy cái kiểu
mì cay cậu tâm sự đầu của video của anh
thôi
nhà nghèo hơi sai sai rồi rõ ràng hả
ý là đây video chỉ với mục đích học đối
nhà tôi cũng bảo tôi sẽ gửi gắm cái việc
à tâm sự này để mà về sau các bạn quen
dần với việc là tôi mà nhảy sang làm gì
Locker như kiểu là vì sao tôi sẽ tâm sự
nhiều hơn cũng cũng cũng vẫn là dân công
nghệ thôi vẫn sẽ có liên quan đến cốt
nhưng mà sẽ
và chia sẻ nhiều cái không chỉ về mỗi
cốt ạ ạ
khoa học TP như nào rồi qua level thì ở
trận Thực ra là chính là cái khóa học
này đây chính là khóa học lập trình web
cơ bản này đây các bạn sẽ biết toàn bộ
cơ bản hết một lượt từ đầu đến cuối
và kết hợp với cả máy Ware để làm đầy đủ
tính năng xem thêm sửa xóa ra mồi biết
qua về những khái niệm kiểu sơn xong rồi
Cookie hôm nay học này đối ngoại và giỏ
và liên quan đến mạng các dư thứ sau đó
thì khi mà nắm tương đối chắc rồi thì sẽ
nhảy sang mô hình mô hình mới C sau đó
thì ok hơn đối tượng sau đó thì nhảy
sang lehrwerk nó có cả hai cái đấy đấy
thì thì nói chung nhà mình thấy cái lộ
trình đấy rất là ổn
Em làm thế nào để cho ra chữ như kiểu
thẻ trong HTML nghĩa ý bạn ở inna Thẩm
thẻ luôn đúng không Thì nó là
chỗ thời cả các bạn phải lưu lại cả đấy
đã đúng không ạ đưa lại rồi hiển thị ra
chữ hay với lại các thẻ ở trong database
xong rồi in nó ra hay như nào Nếu các
bạn muốn in nó ra thuần thì các bạn có
thể dùng cái này dùng có có thẻ để mà in
ra khi mà các bạn ấy cho da mình nó sẽ
Đúng là cái thứ mà các bạn Nhập vào đó
là thẻ free hoặc vợ thể cốt đây hai cái
thẻ này mình thường ai dùng thẻ cốt
nhiều hơn thì vui rồi nó hiển thị nào
trong hơi xấu thể cốt các bạn thể in
vitro vào trong thể cốt thì nó các bạn
Nhập vào cái gì nó sẽ in ra đúng như thế
mà trong khác đẹp
à à
xe máy Ware có khác với SQL Server không
mình nghĩa là sẽ có cú pháp khác khi con
lợn về cơ chế chung thì mình nghĩa
ashworth nó tương đối giống nhau chắc là
nó sẽ có thêm vài cái ngoại lệ là khó
thằng có cái này Có thằng không thôi có
ở đây không chịu tất cả những thằng kia
vẫn có nhá vẫn có nhưng mà ý kiến mình ạ
Có ở đây làm chị ạ có một vài cái thay
đổi nhỏ kiểu là vì ví dụ nhá thằng SQL
Server thì nó có chi cơ liên quan đến
Đăng nhập mẹ của em mình nhớ không có
cái điều đấy Đấy đấy là một trong những
cái thằng kia có thằng này không nhưng
mà chích cơ nó cũng có những cái những
cái gọi tình năng lớn như thế nó vẫn có
Ừ Ok nói chung và bây giờ đến buổi học
rồi thì hôm nay mình đầu tiên mình trả
lời câu hỏi nhưng mà trước khi trả lời
câu hỏi thì mình xin phép và chia sẻ cái
giáo án
à À cái giáo án mà mình từng là mình
từng từng soạn để mà dạy ở trường mình
nói qua một tí về cái giáo án này lại
tâm sự thêm vài phút nữa tranh thủ
thì đây tôi kể cho mấy hôm có chuyện về
trường tôi đó là kiểu
đầu tiên là trưởng chúng tôi thực ra
chuẩn ở trường tôi nhiều các bạn tra thì
nó là chuyên về mạnh chống lại chuyên
viên lập chính nhưng mà cái thầy của tôi
thấy thầy dạy biến Aptech Hồi đấy thời
sự viên Aptech vậy sau đó thầy về trường
này trường đầy À thầy thầy giáo dân
chuyên toán nhưng thầy nhảy sang bên lập
trình ạ sau đó đi vì dân chuyên toán nên
tư duy thấy rất là hồn nè thành ra thầy
cậu làm luôn và thầy cũng rất ạ giỏi
xong việc à
Nói thuyết phục người khác cũng như ở
hiệu quản lý hay ra thầy kiêm luôn được
cả bên quản lý nhân nhân nhân lực cho dù
vẫn là thầy thầy Bình thường thôi nhưng
mà thấy ở kiểu được phong lên làm trưởng
phòng đào tạo nữa là quản lý con người
sau đó thì Thầy nghĩ là trường
thầy nghĩ ra luôn cả giáo án dạy bên lập
trình ở trường của tôi và cùng trường
tôi đã trở thành ra là kiểu nhiều người
biết đến là do ngành bên lập trình hơn
bởi vì ngành lập trình trường tôi thời
mà tôi được đi học đấy thì cái cái đầu
ra của trường tôi tỷ lệ đi làm cao phết
phải bảy mươi phần trăm thôi mà còn hai
thấy đầy dậy công nhận ông ông biết bảy
mươi phần trăm là con số lớn như thế nào
so với đại Em không sợ còn lên nội 50
phần trăm chứ nó 70 phần trăm
đây thì
ạ sau đó thì phải
thấy là cái bằng cấp của chúng tôi về cơ
bản không phải bằng đại học mà sẽ chứng
chỉ nghề ngọn cả là bằng cao đẳng nên
thành ra thầy nên xin liên kết với
trường đại học bên anh Quốc trường đấy
nó có cái bằng quốc tế là cái bàn đấy Nó
còn to hơn cả đại học chính quy ở to hơn
đại học chính quy và được công nhận quốc
tế luôn nhé Ừ đúng rồi thấy hạnh bạn kia
học ở trường mình biết rồi thì
từ thiện thế này là cái chương trình của
nó rất khó Chương trình nó thực ra
chương trình của anh Quốc thì nó sẽ biết
lý thuyết rất nhiều
kiểu dạng kiểu
áo kiểu dạng nào kiểu nó bị lý thuyết
rất nhiều luôn ấy và nhưng mà trường
mình ở trường nghề
Vì thế nên là cái việc mà dạy lý thuyết
như thế nó sẽ đi ngược lại với cái lúc
đầu
Ơ cái định hướng lúc đầu của trường mình
nên là thầy phải cố sao cho là biến cái
việc vừa kết hợp cả việc lý thuyết đấy
vừa phải kết hợp việc thực hành nghĩa
khó rất hiểu
Ừ đúng rồi chương trình đấy chương trình
bị tách cái chương trình đấy à Ở mới có
22 trường đại học ở Hà Nội mới mới nhận
cái dạng cái giáo trình nói chung và
nhận cái chương trình dậy một là FPT 2
Đại học Kinh tế quốc dân như vậy nhưng
Đại học Kinh Tế Quốc gia đình như chết
cái chương trình này ngồi vì không dậy
được Còn Ai Với T thì như không muốn lắm
ở trường nghề nó sẽ giảm thiểu các môn
đại cương khá nhiều đưa như có dậy mày
cái buôn đầy nhưng mà giảm thiểu là cậu
dậy chỉ là chùa không hẳn quan trọng
chính là những môn đấy học vọng tương
đối dễ thôi
Ừ
đúng rồi chương trình thực Hạnh chương
trình nước ngoài đúng nhưng có thực hành
nhiều nhưng mà cái chương trình bị chết
đấy thì nó lý thuyết nó cũng rất rất
nặng và nó toàn bộ bằng tiếng Anh nữa
tay nhau các bạn phải 96 chấm các bạn
mình gửi lãnh hội được thôi Đấy mình
soạn giờ đây mình sẽ cho các bạn xem bây
giờ mình
cô
giáo án của mình lên lại giờ mình sẵn
sàng chia sẻ không ạ Nó không liên quan
gì cả logo chúng tôi
Nhớ lại hồi đấy à Tôi Tôi tự nhiên tôi
phải dậy Cái môn à phải dậy nhưng mà
chưa được dậy thì tôi nhỉ Mày thích dậy
mình anh nữa cơ sở sau đó là toàn bộ
bằng tiếng Anh sợ thật
và đương nhiên là tôi tôi nghe nói đọc
viết thì ta cũng tương đối
để tôi chữa thì IELTS nhưng mà tô ý
nghĩa là tôi tôi tôi để tôi học được
tiếng Anh tương đối rồi đấy Thì hôm nay
tôi chính vì tôi đang nói hơi like hơi
Lê Thế màn chất là tôi định cho mấy ông
biết về cái này cái hôm nay tôi định nói
là BM vs đi em ngoặc nó vô dmanager và
crack manager đấy thì
Ê hồi trước là tôi khi mà nghe kể về cô
đắp Malaysia Tôi rất thích về cái đấy
Tại sao bởi vì ở người ta làm người ấy
sẽ đang ở chuyện kiểu bàn chiến lược
ờ ờ
ở chương trình học không có toán theo
giá
Ừ đúng rồi mà chỉ ông đang họp bị tách
thì ta toàn ra cái thời tôi thì có
cái code Manager thì
nó là kiểu nó nó sẽ làm việc với cả
khách hàng nhựa hơn khách hàng để mà đưa
ra những quyết định của dự án
Ê bà Kiểu Tâm nhìn nhờ chiến lược các tự
thứ không Thời gian cứ xong rồi Kiểu nói
chung là nó lên Nó lên kế hoạch
còn phu Jackman other thì nó sẽ là kiểu
đi và thực hành nó sẽ là kiểu dao pass
là sau đó thì nó phải kiểu và toàn
dashed Line này sao nó quản lý nhân nhân
lực này và luôn vần các thứ thì tôi thấy
thực ra là có nhiều công ty nó gộp chung
hai cái này vào một đặt tên nó leader
thì cho anh
những tùy từng công ty nhé Thực ra là
những kẻ khái niệm về về cái vị trí nhân
lực này nó sẽ có thể khác nhau tùy từng
công ty luôn Ông đặc biệt ông cha mình
cái này ở trên công ty Việt Nam cho bạn
cứ cứ mỗi một công ty nó quan điểm cái
cánh cái việc đấy làm cãi nhau một tí
nhưng mà thực À cái cái này là tôi cái
này tôi soạn vào từ Chuẩn rồi đấy ạ ở
trang nào tôi chả nhớ trang gì Nói Chúng
mày chém nữa ngoài nói chung là cũng
tương đối tín đi ấy kiểu Huế
đại cái thế này là ám chỉ đây đây cũng
là thêm 2 công việc nữa để cho mấy ông
Cân nhắc nói cho một cái thì nó liên
quan đến việc bà ông làm lít Nhưng mà
ông sẽ là kiểu đưa ra quyết định và làm
việc với con người nhiều hơn con người
con người ngoài kiểu khách hàng ấy và
một cái thì ông sẽ cũng là làm lít Nhưng
mà ông sẽ làm việc với đội tách độ
chuyên môn nhiều hơn bóng làm việc nói
chung và ông ông làm theo dạng Suneo
kiểu thế đấy nếu thể cân nhắc việc là
đương nhiên là ông Làm lập trình viên
thì không về sau sẽ phải cân nhắc nhở
ông sẽ thăng tiến lên thành cái gì ông ạ
Chị có hỏi mãi em là trình viên được cái
cậu đấy chỉnh Anh Tuấn gần đây có nói
thôi anh Thiện Thiện Bởi vì tôi bảo là
tôi không muốn làm quản lý con người
nhanh bảo về sau kiểu gì em phải lên làm
lãnh làm kiểu vị trí cao hơn chứ em là
mãi là mã lập trình viên suốt là nó
ngoan khi thì mấy ông mấy ông sẽ phải
cậu nghĩ ông chạy lên và ngồi trước gì
đó không ạ thì mày ông sẽ cân nhắc này
hay đấy Hai cái cái này đó là một cái
thì quản lý quản lý theo kiểu là quản lý
chiến lược sau đó thì nói chuyện với đối
tác nhiều hơn một cái là quản lý đội tá
à Mà ông sẽ vẫn làm việc với độ tách Ông
vẫn sẽ làm công việc tách nhiều hơn để
nếu thể cân nhắc
à à
Ê mấy ông nghỉ rồi Đang bận chuyện đấy
Alo
à Tôi đang chia sẻ Nhắc tôi không tâm sự
thì được
Ừ Ok thôi mà quay lại câu hỏi vậy Nó
tiên thì có bạn không trước họ rất là 2a
các bạn bạn để hỏi thôi Thực ra là cùng
mua mic giống nhau nên chắc nó cùng thu
lại giọng giống nhau đấy
đầu tiên là bạn ấy hỏi ra viết sky kéo
Anh hiểu Phân tích các kiểu thứ thực là
tôi chưa dạy mấy ông vụ đấy mà Đến gần
cuối của cái đùa này tôi sẽ dạy mày
không biết tại sao cái này là phân tích
cụ thể là xem xem xem là cậu thực cao
tính năng đăng nhập đấy thì các bạn sẽ
phải làm từng bước từng bước như nào thì
lăng đăng ký các bạn làm từng bước từng
bước nhạc thậm chí hiển thị Hiển thị tất
cả sản phẩm thì các bạn phải làm từng
bước từng bước như nào nghĩa làm chi rồi
Ai là người có thể thực hiện được tính
năng đấy tính năng lấy bản chất nó là gì
thì dụng tính năng đăng đăng ký chẳng
hạn nó ngoan hôm trước các bạn xem một
cái đăng ký rồi đăng kỵ các bạn bây giờ
chả cốt được tính năng đăng ký rồi nhưng
bây giờ để để mà thử phân tích đó lại
nha Ờ thì đầu tiên nào khi mập thi và
đăng ký chị các bạn sẽ Click vào cái nút
đăng kí ở Đông ạ sau đó thì sẽ hiển thị
ra cái form để các bạn điền thông tin
điền cái gì Điền email và mật khẩu không
ạ sau đó thì các bạn sẽ nhấn nút đăng
nhập sau đó thì nữa thì sẽ nhảy sang ván
sang trang xử lý đăng ký sợ lấy thông
tin mà người dùng bạn Điền về có thể
vides Dạo này kiểm tra không được để
trống các thứ ngoại sau đó thì các bạn
sẽ kết nối cơ sở dữ liệu kiểm tra có có
bất kỳ tài khoản nào ở trong bảng người
dùng bằng khách hàng là bạn nó nhọn dùng
email mật khẩu đã nhập đúng không Đấy
sau đó thì nếu mà chồng thì sao Nếu
không chung thì sao đấy các bạn phải
liệt kê hết tất cả những cái những cái
đấy ra bằng văn xuôi bằng văn xuôi nghĩa
các bạn sẽ phải làm tình năng phân tích
Chị chuẩn chuẩn là thực ra làm cái phần
mềm này các bạn phải phân tích cái đấy
bằng văn xuôi trước gần như kiểu sông Mã
giả trước trước khi mà các bạn cốt nhưng
mà vì bản chất là các bạn còn chưa biết
được chốt mình cái bạn này như thế nào
nên thành ra là tôi phải làm ngược lại
đó tôi phải dậy Nếu cốt trước đã sau đó
thì tôi mới dậy Mà ông viết tài liệu về
nó còn đến đồ ăn 2 đến đồ ăn hay thì
không phải làm Huawei đồng ạ nghĩa là
mấy ông phải phân tích phải thiết kế sau
đó Nói chung phải làm hết tất cả những
cái kiểu những cái đầu trước trước khi
mà Mấy ông đến cốt Nếu không được anh
ngại nhất về mình cái đâu đấy nhưng mà
khi mà các bạn phân tích xong hết rồi
thì các bạn Cốt và cốt chỉ dựa theo cái
đấy thôi thì nó mới chọn ngoạn phải có
tài liệu chứ để mà người sau người ta
không nhìn vào cốt của mấy ông người ta
nhìn vào tài liệu ở làm và đặc biệt là
đôi khi vứt cái tài liệu đấy cho bất kỳ
ai Ừ cũng được chứ nếu mà không gửi ông
tự nghĩ ra cốc à đúng ạ Nếu bắt buộc
phải có phải có tài liệu nó phải có
chuẩn như thế nếu người có tài liệu và
về sau người ta sẽ gửi trong tài liệu để
mấy ông
Anh để máy mài ông nhìn vào tài liệu này
mới uống cốt mà đóng lại
Ừ đúng rồi mu nữa
ở gần đây tôi học liên thông được cũng
có phải môn nó có nhắc đến vụ này quản
lý mềm xô ngồi các thứ có
ông ngoại môn phân tích nhất thì thiết
kế hệ thống có rồi cũng mệt vãi Hình như
tôi cũng có bài tập về cái vụ đấy à
bí ngô mới không hiểu gì tôi không đấy
mẹ không phải có những cái đấy trước
à Tôi đang dạy tôi bảo tôi dạy nghề nên
Hãy nghe tôi dậy mấy ông nó đôi khi mà
nhìn ra được kết quả trước đúng ạ nhưng
mà để mà làm chuẩn từ đầu đến cuối đứng
yên kiểu gì Miễu ngày có nếu không tránh
được
Ừ nhưng mà đương nhiên để tôi bảo ở nếu
không phải Ông làm cái đấy ông thấy chán
không ạ Ok thì về sau mấy ông sẽ tập
trung vào pin code nhiều hơn không nhất
thiết mấy ông vì sao đăng ký mấy ông sẽ
phải làm những cái việc đấy
Tôi học nghề tôi không không phải học
cái đấy nhiều Hồi đấy tôi cũng được học
giống như là tôi đang dạy mấy ông này
tôi đang dạy mấy ông những cái mà tôi đã
từng được học
Ừ Thế hồi Mở tôi đang ôm đúng đầy giáo
án giáo trình mà hồi ấy tôi điều hòa với
tao giận mày ông thôi Đó là theo kiểu là
tôi sẽ học cốt trước sau đó đi về sau
tôi làm tài liệu đấy được không ạ
tôi thấy tôi thấy nó hiệu quả với tôi
thế nên tôi đang dạy lại mấy ông như thế
đương nhiên là tôi tôi không chết ấy còn
nói cho tôi đã chỉnh sửa một vài cái đó
tôi đã giảm tải phải cái mà Tôi thấy à
rồi đấy Tôi không Không cần phải nghe
những điều đấy Mình chưa đủ quan trọng
Tôi đã giảm tải mấy ông rồi nên em mấy
ông bây giờ mới thấy tôi dậy nó khá là
mượt và nhanh nhanh ấy phải rùng mình
anh Bởi vì ạ Thôi đấy tôi đi tôi học
HTML CSS là Swift xô ngồi TP phải 34
tháng Có chứ phải đến bây giờ đã nhảy
sang TP đoán thôi à
Ừ ok Tiếp theo là cái vụ ở đây là tôi có
hứa cũng ngồi bạn nào đó
2095 tên ở đây đó là nếu là bạn đấy mà
làm đồ án này tương đối thành công thì
thôi sẽ vào Đà Nẵng có thể thế nói rõ mà
phải đợi bước dịch đã thì nên là mấy anh
em ở đây mà có ông nào Đà Nẵng thì ra là
điểm danh phát thì tôi thấy đông đủ làm
buổi offline Ngoại Ô
anh ở đây sẽ có tôi có quen cũng ba bốn
ông ở trong Đà Nẵng thôi từng vào Đà
Nẵng một lần trần đấy khá thân thiện
Ừ ông anh tôi từng rơi hai lần cái điện
thoại iPhone iPhone 10 Nói chung là thời
đại hiện Hồi đấy là iPhone này IPhone
mới nhất rồi hai lần trên taxi người ta
được gọi trả lại
sự thay đổi thực hiện vãi chưởng
à à
em hỏi ông kia ở Đà Nẵng ngon
ở Sài Gòn thì kiểu gì tôi bảo tôi định
sẽ vào
ở nhà
đợi bất dịch cho tôi sẽ vào đã Sài Gòn
trước cơ à
anh nói nói như kiểu mình là người nổi
tiếng Nga không có lỗi gì em bao nhiêu
mà ý tôi là kiểu Tôi sẽ mở offline có
thể không phải mỗi cho anh em mình mà
cho cả dư tin community anh bởi vì mấy
ông từng câu ca rồi mấy cái kiểu tỉnh
lớn này từ thiếu ca rồi nó lắm chị ạ Mấy
anh Tân tổ chức offline ở hai tỉnh lớn
kia mà những cái tình lớn còn lại thì
không tổ chức Offline lần nào thì thì ca
Tôi từng nói là bởi vì không có ban quản
trị nào đấy vào đấy tổ chức cả thì lần
này tôi vào thì tôi có thể dẫn sẽ tôi
trước đúng không ạ ạ
Ẩm Thực ra là không quan trọng mình
nhiều người lắm nhiều người lắm chứ Tôi
đang sợ quá tay anh cậu ít thôi tầm
lý tưởng nhất ở thực ra chỉ cần mà mà
23 bàn cà phê giống kiểu hai bà nội lậu
ấy bây giờ kiểu đứng đứng từ đừng những
từ đầu cái bàn lại rồi đến cuối lần kia
kêu mà người kia chả nghe thấy gì vậy
Bốn ngoại nếu lúc đầy cho không nói
chuyện được với nhau với ông kéo chỉ
ngồi vắt thôi
à à
a tiếp theo nhé học học về an ninh mạng
Thực ra tôi có từng học ạ an ninh mạng
và biết qua thì tôi thấy thực ra là
không cần đại học ngôn ngữ lập trình lắm
anh không cần lắm Bởi vì A vẫn có thể có
theo kiểu
ở Mỹ hay vẫn còn anh quan bởi vì có viết
bot các thứ nhưng mà không cần lắm chủ
yếu về phần cứng thì đúng và mạng nữa
anh em hãy ở thời ra các bạn lên tra
mạng nhiều hơn nó hỏi trực tiếp như một
thằng dân công gần không liên quan lắm
không ạ tiếp theo là hôm chưa có bạn hỏi
về cái season flash vào sao không áp
dụng cái này thì chở Hôm nay tôi sẽ ăn
dụng luôn này và hầm ăn xét nữa ham ăn
xét là hàm gì À đây mình trả lời nó câu
này trước khi nhảy sang cốt nhé Thì có
bạn bảo là Clone của web khác kiểu như
thế nào thực ra là các bạn đã từng nghe
khái niệm về chromaweb thích cám chim
tao copy hết toàn bộ web khác về trong
ống Hiệp cái quét khác về thời ra các
bạn khó là thể load web khác về được trừ
khi các bạn hoàn nuôi cá tải hết toàn bộ
hgcs nó về thì chồng có về giống hệt nó
chứ không còn khái niệm mà lắm chị ạ Có
được cả cốt hổ cốt của nó thì không có
gì cô nói Chủ yếu là xử lý bác em thì
các bạn sẽ không mờ biết được Cố tỏ như
nào à Còn nếu làm chỉ các bạn copy và
giao diện thì cái đấy làm được không ạ
ở đây mình sẽ nói về hàm ăn xét đầu tiên
hôm trước ở các bạn thấy cái vụ đăng ký
à à
dịch vụ đăng ký này thì các bạn thấy à À
nhầm đang xuất đăng xuất thì hôm trước
mình nó là có hai cách một là các bạn
dùng season flash assistant
trên sân golf để mà xóa toàn bộ cái đang
lưu trong sân đi
như thế này nhưng mà thực ra cách này
như mình đã nói Thực ra là nó không hay
hiểu nghĩa về sau mình còn là liên quan
đến sẽ dần nữa đó là chỉ mang cái giỏ
hàng các bạn không thể đăng đăng xuất ở
bài thơ cái giỏ hàng người ta được trải
nghiệm mình không tốt nên là các bạn chỉ
nên xóa những cái mà các bạn đang lưu
trong thời kỳ đăng nhập tất cả ID hoặc
rõ tên đó ông ạ thì thì
dù kẻ phàm ăn xét này nó xóa đi cải đang
lưu
khi cài nó đang tồn tại ạ đương nhiên là
cái này nếu sử đang trống thì nó vẫn
không báo lỗi gì cả và cái này nó sẽ
không chỉ bạn đấy bảo là làm việc với
mỗi mảnh nó không đúng cái ăn sẽ này thể
xóa được cảm biến hay bất cứ cái gì cả
Tôi cho ông một ví dụ đơn giản đi mình
có test chấm pp này cái phê ở đây là sự
đối là a = 5 này xong rồi ê trôi đâu là
a này kiểu như này em một cái rất đơn
giản à
I have shown that này cho P đấy
đấy mời bạn phải đi là số 50 ạ nhưng bây
giờ sửa mình sẽ ăn xét đô la ngày trước
đi Tôi có xóa bina đi các bạn sẽ thấy là
biển a Không Tồn tại nói chuyện đó giảm
đi đâu Anh sẽ xóa đi một cái gì đó khỏi
bộ nhớ đệm vừa để tiết kiệm bộ nhớ và để
cho cái bé này không tồn tại nữa cái ăn
xét này được Dùng khá nhiều về sau các
bạn sẽ thấy được Dùng khá nhiều tiền
hình giống như tôi đang làm ở công ty
giờ thực ra có nhiều dữ liệu nó lớn quá
các bạn không sử dụng nó nữa ở dưới các
bạn muốn cậu giải phóng ra mỏng Anh ấy
thì các bạn sẽ ăn xe đi đứng yên à sẽ có
một thời gian là để cái file chạy sóng
thực thi rồi ram nóng sẽ bị xóa và ram
thôi nhưng mà nó vẫn về các bạn thì mình
xóa nhanh nó luôn đi thì các bạn sử dụng
ăn sét Đồ ngoại mà
a tiếp theo là
flash thì đây mình sẽ nói qua
ờ ờ
À hôm trước là mình nói về cái vụ là
thật sự là
khi đăng nhập bại thì phải Đợi mình tí
đã nhìn thấy
an Đăng ký Đăng ký Các bạn nhớ Cái vụ
hôm trước về cái vụ đăng ký này lại thử
nhé
size up trên phê này
ở đây cũng trước là sự Càn Long hacker
Đông ạ ạ
ở phần này nó nguy cơ tay
À hôm trước của ký Email này rồi em mình
đăng ký lại như này bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ
báo lỗi gọi chồng email rồi nhưng mà Cái
lỗi này để hai địa chỉ như thế này tất
cả bên mình tải đạn cha nó lại thì chị
Đỗ này tôi giờ xử lý copy cái lỗ này cho
một bạn ABC Eyes các bạn ấy lại hiểu lại
xem rồi cả lỗi này sẽ trải nghiệm người
dùng để không tốt cái lỗ này chỉ cần nên
Hiển thị một lần thôi thì thì nên là sẽ
có khái niệm mà system flash tất cả chị
ạ là nó lưu đại season vừa nói hiển thị
đúng một lần thấy cả tôi biết đấy biến
lauras thôi chứ áp dụng nó trên PC rồi
để tôi thử tra Google phát nhá á
các em à
từ đó làm cơ chế là như thế nào
ở hà nộiăn xét ở đây thôi ok lẽ là lấy
nó ra in là ra cho ăn xét xóa nó đi ok
thì các bạn vừa rồi thấy được có cốt rồi
đấy đúng ạ đó rất là đầu tiên mình sẽ xử
lý đăng đăng ký này
ở đây cái đoạn này thay vì các bạn như
thế này Xóa đi này
đây cái đoạn thông báo lỗi đúng ạ hả đi
Sủa đúng không ạ Mình sẽ có season start
này
sau đó thì mình sẽ lưu vào trong sân một
cái biến gyro này sẽ bằng cái đoạn suối
này như thế này vừa có bạn vẫn sẽ lưu
hướng về những thứ còn ở bên này thì các
bạn sẽ là
thì mình sẽ restart Ở đây thư da như tôi
đã từng nói phát ở trên cùng nó vẫn hơn
đầy hội ở đây cũng được đây mình sẽ là
ít
Ừ nếu có tồn tại là Issac season Hero
đúng ạ
đều có trong vệ sinh thì mình sẽ cho
assistant
Hero sau đó thì ăn xét nó đi để xóa nó
đi in một lần rồi xóa đi như này à
ở đây Các bạn thấy đầu tiên là bây giờ
không có gì mình chưa lưu trong thí sinh
tạo lại
về làm hacker
này mật khẩu không quan trọng không ạ ạ
á khẩu nhạc ấy chung email rồi nó tại
lại tra thì có bạn sẽ không thấy cái lỗi
đấy nữa đây sẽ là áp dụng cái sân flash
con Bộ hôm nay mình dạy về bánh quy đúng
không ạ với Cookie thì được à Mấy ông bà
hỏi tôi tại sao tên nó có kì đâu không
biết giải thích nha đi cái đấy tên của
nó đặt từ lâu quý không nó cũng được Tại
sao là tới nó bất vậy Bắp thì ít ra là
bởi vì đã từng có một con bọ ở trong máy
tính mà không có thật tên nó bất con
quốc kỳ tôi không không hiểu thật
Nhưng mà đại khái đồng tiền này các bạn
sẽ phân biệt à season Cookie và thuận
chỉ cách nữa mình sẽ giải thích qua cái
ảnh này mình đang mở ba cái tát về nó
bởi vì mỗi cái bài đăng nó có một cái ra
ý nào đó không đụng hẳn và thằng viên
phải là mình phải mở 3 bài nhưng mà mình
thấy cái bài này có cái ảnh này Thực ra
tôi
em thấy cái ảnh này khá ổn này mấy ông
thấy lúc đầu có bốn cái bánh quy ở trên
cái máy này không ạ sau đó thì khi mà
kết nối qua server đó nó sẽ có thêm một
cái bánh quy và gửi lại cho ông Thành 5
cái bánh quy không ạ Ở đây thì ra nó
không phải nói đúng lắm không đúng lắm
lại sao vì thứ nhất
ở đó nè
ở đầu tiên tôi nói nó về cái đúng đi đó
đúng à khi mong kết nối mất cái gì nó sẽ
luôn Hỏi ông cái quyền thường Xuka nó
hỏi cho có thôi Được cái kiểu gì nó cũng
sẽ lấy những cái hỏi đấy là bởi vì theo
quy tắc của bên châu Âu bây giờ nó bắt
buộc cả nó luôn phải nói lại em nuôi dù
nhà ạ là
mày có cho lấy cô kia không hôm trước
rồi có câu chuyện cười cái này rồi Bây
giờ tôi có lưu lại cái đấy thì bạn
có ai nghĩ tui xem cùng
khi nghe tin mới to
mà sắp được con khỉ như cô thì đố vui
cuộc thi selfie now You can tell me Okay
I
thì ra là có những cái những cái kiểu và
cái MI hài phải có kỹ lại khá nhiều rồi
í
thế nhưng đại khái như thế bên châu Âu
bây giờ đang chơi trò là kiểu hỏi là
kiểu phải cho tao cho tao kiểu truy cập
và quốc kỳ của mày đã sau đó thì mới cho
Duy tiếp Nhưng mà bản chất thì dùng ra
Swift với nó vẫn lấy được rồi nó bảo rồi
bởi vì trâu bây giờ đang có bật lại như
thế nhưng thực ra thì mẹ không chấp nhận
hay không thì nó cũng sẽ lấy thôi
a
tiếp theo là nó lấy xong rồi nó sẽ làm
gì còn chết rồi Nó lấy để mà để mà nó có
thể thu thập thông tin từ của ông để Mã
Phục phục vụ cho ông tốt hơn thường ý
thế nên là thật ra cái trong Cookie đôi
khi nó không còn những cái thứ có thể
nhạy cảm trong đấy Cường chỉ ở những cái
thông tin mà những cái trong cái ông
dùng truy cập Thấy cái là nó cũng hơi bị
sai một tí bởi vì dựa theo những trang
web của ông truy cập thành ra là nó đề
xuất cho ông quảng cáo rất là nhiều điển
hình là mấy ông thấy rõ ràng là ông chắc
ông theo ông và bất kỳ Trang web nào sau
lúc sau quảng cáo ở trên Google nó quảng
cáo Facebook đi xuống vậy Rất chuẩn em ạ
Đấy Chúng tôi là bởi vì nó lấy Cookie
đầu tiên thì ông và những trong Peppa
trang web ấy đưa nó tự động ghi công ty
và sinh máy của ông đấy Sau đó thì khi
mà ông vào lại Facebook hay ở Google thì
nó lại lấy lại Cookie từ những thằng kia
xong nó đề xuất quảng cáo thành ra ở
Quảng cáo rất là chuẩn ông vừa xem bài
đăng nào vừa xem cái sản phẩm về máy
A gọi đồ cho người lớn ở ạ Đấy sau đó
thì lúc sau đề xuất một loạt ở trên
quảng cáo của ông ông không hiện lại sa
lạc Nhạn không đi giải thích trong video
nha em ạ đấy thì cái đấy là do cái cơ
chế có key này cái lý do mà Mấy ông lướt
mày cái những cái mà cũng không muốn đi
suốt quảng cáo thì mới ông nên dùng bằng
trình chuẩn danh đúng không ạ thì nó sẽ
không khí quốc kỳ của ông và nó không
đấy không khí của ông ạ
Ừ ok thấy là tôi bảo cái này không đúng
là điểm là đôi khi ạ Nó sẽ lấy và nó sẽ
đọc nhưng mà chưa chắc màu ghi vào có tí
đường cái nó sẽ đi vào
đông ạ
Ừ chứ không phải lại trước vợ ở trang
nào nó sẽ ghi Cookie vào đâu có vài
trang nó kiểu có ngoài xanh nó ghi là
thôi có vay trả chị đọc thôi
a và và cái Xin thí sinh hôm trước tội
nhấn mạnh đi nhà mạng lại Thứ nhất là nó
lưu lại sự sợ vợ nó không ạ Tại sao bởi
vì a thằng cu kia nó ngược lại họ sẽ lưu
lại trên lên cryin máy khách Hà Đông ạ
và như tôi không cho tôi cũng có nói đó
là khi mà mày ông Lưu Xuân Mãn chất là
nó lưu lại trong Cookie trên máy ông
để mà để mở dùng cái khi mà truy cập vào
thì cứ ghi sẽ được gửi lên rồi mà sắp
nhận cái sĩ Trần kia đều ngoạn nhưng mà
cái key này nó lại được mã hóa một cách
tự động nên thành ra ông khó mà ông sửa
được nó để đổi thành sân của thằng khác
à
A và season này nó sẽ bởi vì nó lưu lại
trên máy chủ khó sửa tay béo để xem qua
cái này Cookie được lưu trên trình duyệt
người dùng này sẽ dần không được lưu nó
lưu lại trên server đó ông ạ
oke có thể dễ dàng thay đổi bởi vì nó
lừa trên mái nhà dụng nó thì ở file tex
thôi nó fytech nghe mấy ông mở lên Nếu
không sửa được con cái này thì nó không
dễ sửa vì nó lưu trên server rồi
ở đây và Cookie nó thường thường là
nghe thưởng thức ca ít khi hết hạn lắm
thường là đôi khi có người lại có kia
thành vĩnh viễn cơ ngày ăn trẻ nhỏ ít
khi được xóa Hoàn season thì nó lại giữa
ngắn đôi khi ông Tắt trình duyệt ông
ngắt kết nối cái thằng server sẽ chấm
dứt luôn để sơ sinh sản của ông Khi mà
Ông nhắn kết nuôi nó bé tùy từng vài
trang
như tôi đã nói thẳng ra là mấy ông bạn ạ
Ừ anh điêu thế Bây giờ em tắt hẳn
Facebook rồi Sao em ở lại như này anh
thấy lại truy cập vào không cần đăng
nhập nóng ạ Thực ra bản chất ở đây nó đã
kết thúc thí sinh của ông rồi nó kết
thúc season rồi nhé Chẳng qua nó dùng
Cookie cũ của ông vẫn còn hiệu lực để mà
tạo phiên đăng nhập mới cho ông Liên
hàng ra làm mấy ông thấy à Nếu không cần
phải đăng nhập lại thực ra bản chất là
nó đã dùng Cookie để mà đăng nhập lại
cho ông rồi nên là hôm nay tôi sẽ dạy
mấy ông điều đấy nếu không sẽ làm tình
năng mà tính năng khi mà đăng nhập vào
nó sẽ có nút là nút ghi nhớ tôi được
Nhạn các bạn biết cái nút để không ạ
I say in nhiều hôm trước tôi biết xanh
tại vậy
Ừ em gọi cho dì không chưa thì sáng đã
à à
Ừ thì ở đây sẽ có cái nút à
à cậu ghi nhớ đăng nhập không ạ bấm vào
mình sẽ đây là ở kiểu các bạn khi vào
lại đăng nhập vào luôn không ạ ạ
em không có key dài nhất không phải 135
lậu nó thì vĩnh viễn đấy nó sẽ không
không Mở Xóa được
ý là nốt thêm cảnh nữa này
Ừ cái cái này cái thứ ở bên này không có
đây đó là Cúc y phù hợp với lưu lại
những thông tin giải hạn Không nhẹ cả
không nhận cả một vì sao Bởi vì anh mà
lưu lại trên máy khách Hà nên là một Nó
ông những cái nhạy cảm quá giả sự như
cái đăng nhập chuẩn bị tôi sẽ làm thì
ông nên mã hóa để người dùng không
100 kiểu sửa nó để mà đăng nhập vào tài
khoản người khác tí rồi sẽ phải là vụ
đấy
A và lưu lại những thông tin điện hình
dạng giống như ông trình sửa cái gì đó
thường là chỉnh sửa về à
xe địa hình nhá Tiền hình xe máy
ở cây Trang Leo này không nên thầy Tôi
đang để nó là nền tối đúng không ông để
nó là niềm tối Tất cả chỉ là tôi không
thể đăng nhập vào cái trang web này đúng
không Tôi thử copy cho mấy ông ạ Sau này
Ý anh nói với anh nhìn tuổi này
vợ yêu nhỉ Thế giờ nó vẫn ăn cốc kỳ thôi
vậy
khi bật đèn sáng nhé
hai cây đèn sáng ấy
ý là không không Thằng này mặc định Nam
để tối rồi đấy mẹ Mẹ tôi từ đội để đây
nên sáng đi Ok đến sáng nhé ạ
chú chó mặc mặc định cái này lên tối Ok
mày Ông thấy nhá thời đó là nền sàn đúng
không
thứ Hai lên tối đúng không Tại sao lại
có điều này sẽ sẽ xảy ra khi mà tôi tải
lại sang thì nó vẫn là nền tối không
phải lý giá mọi việc thằng thằng này nó
không yêu cầu tôi đăng nhập ừ nóng và nó
lưu lại cái việc thay đổi cái cái giao
diện của tôi mà trong Cookie nên ăn hàng
ra khi mà tôi vào bằng ẩn danh nó không
lấy được Coca của tôi nên nó lấy lại mặc
định còn nếu mà Bây giờ tôi vào lại thời
trang này tắt đi mở lại như này thì mới
Ông thấy nó vẫn giao diện sáng bởi vì nó
lấy Cookie của tôi đấy một trong những
cái đơn giản đó làm gì ạ mày ông đôi khi
không cần lại lưu cái gì đó lên con nó
nhập gì cả mà ông Chị lưu lại cấu hình
người dùng thôi cũng là một cái người
dùng chương trình Cái gì đó mà và có thể
ông lưu lại giỏ hàng của người dùng Ông
thấy thật ra có nhiều cái kiểu lựa giò
hàng cũng qua cũng kia được đón chị rồi
ông vào một trang nào đó không đặt các
sản phẩm sản phẩm đó ngoạn cho ông ông
đã ông đâu Yêu cầu phải đăng nhập mà
mông vẫn làm được cái được thêm giỏ hàng
không ạ sau đó thì ông tự Nhưng chán rồi
ông
Ừ ông tắt Sư Cái trang web phải đi sau
đó vài ngày sau ông lại nhớ lại trang
web để ông vào lại ông thấy rõ hàng của
ông vẫn còn bản chất là do nó là dùng
Cốc đi đấy có thể nó sẽ dùng
localstorage nữa cũng là một cách nhưng
mà về cơ bản thì hai thằng nó giống nhau
nó lưu lại trên máy người dùng và thông
tin đấy không phải thông tin ngay cả
thông tin thấy hoàn toàn người dùng sửa
cũng được không sao cả đều ạ Nó không
phải thông tin nhạy cảm còn trong sân
Thì nó sẽ khác các bạn phải phân biệt kỳ
diệu này season nó sẽ lưu lại không tin
ai cả Thì thì những cái còn đăng nhập
hãy cứ thử thứ
A và cuối cùng mình nói nốt thêm cái nữa
nhanh này nó cách thưa cách thì mình đã
từng nói qua việc là hồi mà mình chỉnh
sửa CF thì giao diện đôi khi không Lập
tức thay đổi vì trình duyệt đôi khi nó
tự động như lại cách và thận chế ở lập
trình viên mình có thể
sf Cái trình duyệt lưu lại cách nhiều
cái để cho trang web nó tải nhanh hơn
nhược điểm là khi mà Mấy ông trình sửa
giao diện rồi thì đôi khi giao diện cũ
vẫn còn hiển thị xe máy người dùng bởi
vì cái đấy nó lưu lại trên cách của
trình duyệt người dùng cái đấy khó mà ép
người dùng khó mà ép người dùng kiểu xóa
được cái cáp người dùng phải tự thủ thủ
công làm điều đấy chứ mình không thể bị
không thể hiểu dạng là
những
kiểu cắm thiệp được và cách của trình
duyệt người dùng nên là hồi trước phải
có chơi trò là hồi nãy tôi nhớ là cái
trinh cái cái cái giao diện các trang
web để nó bị lỗi lỗ rất nặng luôn nên
thành ra là kiểu mà lỡ lưu cách cài rồi
nên là phải đổi cái tên miền điều hướng
tên miền sang hẳn để kiểu ví dụ là phim
mới Z chẳng ngại thương thế để mà để mà
không lưu cách của cái giao diện nữa mấy
ông hình dung không Thế à thế là cũng
hơi bị nhược điểm vụ đấy nghĩa ông sửa
xong đôi khi nó không đồng bộ
anh Bởi vì nó có căn cứ cách mà đồng
tiền hình dạng dạng như là thế giới di
động đi
cái gì đập nát ngang
hai tay nếu không thể hai giây rồi đúng
không ạ tải lại này 1,3 giây này Tại lại
nữa này 1,3 1,1 giây này Tại nữa 1,1 đây
Tại sao từ hai giây mà xuống hàng như
thế chỉ với đơn giản vì nó đã lưu cách
lại khá nhiều địa hình lưu cách lại để
hình cái Tháng 3 này hai cái thứ
đi hoa cà hoa còn lưu lại sẵn mà cái CS
mở ra Switch để mà khi mà tải lại trang
gần như là gần như là chị thư gan là cái
những cái mọi ý thay đổi ví dụ như là
cái ba nâu này cùng hai ba ngày nó mới
hay đổ một phát thì nó lưu lại cách
trong 23 ngày nó ngoại kiểu gì thế ạ
Ừ đúng rồi Mày không có thể sửa lại
đường dẫn của xe hết thì nó sẽ sẽ xóa
kết đi thôi Nhưng mà đấy là ông sửa sẽ
còn đang nói là cách cả hmg nữa thì thì
mấy ông sửa kiểu gì thì cũng chỉ có thể
là kẹo điều hướng sang trang web khác
thôi
Ừ ok Nói chung là hơi lan man một tí bởi
vì cốt Hôm nay thực ra rất ngắn thôi thử
cho mấy ông xem có cô trong máy Nhắn
cướp tôi phải là nam không mấy ông ấy
kiểu hôm nay thế thôi à đây tôi sẽ cho
ông Ví dụ nhé cơ mình sẽ làm tính năng
đang đăng đăng nhập không ạ Và khi nhờ
đăng nhập
khi đăng nhập với ông trước làm tôi em
mình sẽ ăn cái nhớ đăng nhập không ạ
thì mình sẽ có cái nút
ghi nhờ đăng nhập
thường thường là cái này chết bốc
mà thường mình sẽ cho cái lên như thế
này ghi nhớ nạ
phó Bây giờ xin phép mình đổi nó thành
mét ghét thì mấy ông dễ hình dung hơn về
cái này đã Đợi thì đợi thì tôi sẽ tạm
bên A short size 18 ẩn cái đoạn này đi
đã Để tôi cho ông xem về cái việc khi nó
đẩy lên web thì nó sẽ như nào là sử tôi
không Điền gì đây nhá tích và ghi nhớ
Đăng nhập Thơ nó nghiệp này nếu không sẽ
thấy ở đây không điện gì Ok nó trống ghi
nhớ sẽ ngon không hiểu là cái gì nhưng
nó ghi nhớ nó sẽ ăn ngon rồi nhá Thế là
tôi thử tắt cái này đi cẩn đăng nhập thì
ông ấy Ông thấy là nó không hề Truyền Kỳ
anh lên luôn đúng không ạ ạ
à à
Ừ nó chỉ lưu cách xét
ừ ừ
vì nó thực ra nó vẫn có thể lưu cách
được hml theo kiểu là mình nhớ mình mình
nhớ ở như thế thì công ty mình đang áp
dụng cái kiểu lưu kết HTML mà chẳng qua
mình không không nhớ cách làm như là
thôi Hình như có hoặc các công ty mình
điều kể trên server in nó ra bởi vì công
ty mình đang dùng mà da Swift dùng nắp
loa CS để mà sinh ra hát lời sau đó đi
cách lại cái đoạn 200l nó đã xử lý xong
Anh không dùng tiếng Anh nữa à Ok vậy
Giống như nhanh cho chứng nhiệt nhưng mà
Mấy ông thôi quay lại đây một tí đi
Anh ấy thì cái á khi cây email và
password này Đúng không mấy ông thấy rõ
ra là khi mà tích tích vào thì có để em
hai chị không thích thì nó không đẩy
luôn luôn nhe Cái đoạn này nó hơi khác
một tí Mình sẽ phải kiểm tra nó có tồn
tại thôi là được có tồn tại thôi làm chị
đã có lưu không quan tâm với giá trị của
nó nữa còn nếu mà không đẩy lên thì rõ
không lưu nóng ạ tôi để nói tiếng Anh
nhá Ok cảm ơn bạn nhé mình cũng nên thế
mình nên kiểu một thống nhất là toàn bộ
tiếng anh hay tưởng bộ tiếng Việt đừng
có lừa anh ấy việc em như thế là cốt tủy
bây giờ động não
Anh An ninh đội nói như này à Ê mày tải
lại cho em chưa chắc lại đúng ạ bây giờ
xử mới điện nữa bình thường 5 hacker
một chút Mật khẩu là cái gì nhỉ
Ừ thôi tôi tự hack chính tôi đi nó sẽ để
như này
a cho một bóng một như này sẽ không sao
như thế này không cần điền Email cũng
được sẽ vào tài khoản của bất kỳ lên một
đấy tôi tự hay chính tôi nhé
thì nó sẽ ăn ghi nhớ không ạ
khi đăng nhập này
ở đó thì bạn chất ở bên này sẽ vẫn giống
như hôm trước nha lần này mình sẽ là kèm
theo cái cái nhớ nhưng mà mình sẽ làm đi
Sao mình sẽ ít reset lại còn đều có
đều có remember không ạ member có ý Nhớ
thì mình giả sử mình cho remember
bạn Chu đi tức à đúng đi eo thì bờ bằng
phone đi
sai hoặc như này
dự báo trước mà nghỉ nên bà không biết
là hôm trước hết khủng như thế nào ghê
lắm đấy à
Em nói trước bây giờ Bà Xã Đàn Đăng nhập
thành công rồi hack rồi cái chị sẽ tao
được không ạ sau đó mình sẽ có season
start này mình sẽ lưu lại
à à
vì mình lưu lại trong season các thứ thứ
đó ngoại
mình làm lại cái vụ hôm trước nhé đó là
mình sẽ lấy cái người đầu tiên mình đăng
nhập thành công không ạ sau đó lưu lại
ID người dùng lưu lại tên người dùng nữa
và khi mà đăng nhập thành công và kèm
theo có ghi nhớ từng nghĩ sẽ lại ít em
bờ nghĩa là nếu nếu có ghi nhớ phải
không ạ Mình sẽ có setcookie
anh sex kỳ Tôi không nhớ của Pháp vào
năm đâu Cho tôi xem nhé Sẽ có Kỳ P
a A nó viết liền à Mà sao sẽ có kỳ okay
đây cú pháp xe cũ Kia của nó sẽ mạnh tí
Anh tên của Kia này giá trị quốc kia
thời gian nếu ông sẽ thấy ở đây nó sẽ có
thời gian ở đây nó lại mình cứ đơn giản
thôi nếu mà ông không nhớ tắm
86.400 là số dây một ngày ông mấy
60 X60 x240 ạ xong nhấn 30 ngày thì sẽ
một tháng không ạ Giờ cái quan trọng vào
đây mình uống nhỉ Có thêm cái sao mày
nón trước than này để làm gì tha mày là
lấy thời gian số dân hiện đại
Tại sao học bởi quy chế của Hàn Quốc kỳ
này nhá Cái này là tên của cái Cookie mà
mày ông sẽ đọc này Thứ hai là giá trị cũ
kỹ này Thứ ba là cái cái thôi jean kaki
sẽ hết hạn người ông phải xét thời gian
cũng có khi hết hạn nhé thì thường là
kiểu lưu ghi nhổ hết thường anh chỉ
trong vòng hai tháng mà một tháng thôi
Thì mấy ông sẽ nghĩ là chỉ đoạn này đủ
nhưng mà không thì ra là có khi nó sẽ
phải xét theo cả là tính từ thời điểm Và
cho đến thời điểm tương lai nên thành
nhà phải thêm thời gian hiện tại nữa
được cộng thêm thời gian tương lai thì
ra là như thế này cái đoạn như thế này
thì ông không cầm đâu Ông bỏ đi đấy thì
cú phát ở đây nó sẽ sự lưu gọi không Khi
mà là đưa member chẳng hạn thế sau đó đi
ông sẽ lưu lại gì trong về Quan trọng là
bây giờ ông sẽ lưu lại gì để mà hiểu
được là tí mà thằng nào có Cookie này
thì mình sẽ đăng nhập được vào đông ạ
Ừ cái quan trọng ở đây thường là hồi
trước tôi dậy cho sinh viên đơn giản là
tôi lưu lại mã người dùng với sóng này
tôi thử lưu lại mã dùng nhé xong một tí
mấy ông sẽ thấy là nó có thể nguy hiểm
nha tham này
cộng với giờ sự nếu không rút toán đi 60
X60 nhân 24
X30 thì sẽ ra 1 tháng đúng không ạ Cái
xong thế chả bạn ạ
ô tô tại trai nha
khi đăng nhập thành công vào nhấn vào nó
không thể cả diện ấy DJ cukiu mày không
xem Cookie nhé ở đó thì mới Ông thấy có
biến đương m lưu lại mã vòng 1 idea một
đông lạnh Ừ nó như này đăng nhập thành
công không ạ
à Mấy giờ thì giả sử là bây giờ khi mà
tôi và lại cái răng sai này tôi vào lại
trang sai này
FPT này
Chị Thơ ca khi mà vào lại sang chai này
mà tôi đã đăng nhập rồi thực ra là không
cần nên hiện sĩ là cái sao nhập nữa mà
phải vào thẳng luôn cái tài khoản của
tôi không ạ tất làm chị đã sao và đầu
tiên là bây giờ tôi kiểm tra là ít thôi
mờ season start Nếu mà có xin thì tôi sẽ
phải điều hướng với cái Trang chăng
người dùng luôn sẽ là start này và riêng
cái vụ đấy thì nên để trên cùng như hơn
bởi vì a điều hướng ở luôn lệ trên cùng
đều hướng nó sẽ bị lỗi nếu mà các bạn in
ra bất kỳ giá trị như thế này các bạn
không dùng header được nghe các bạn sẽ
có đầy nó trên cùng như thế này thì
start ở trên cung xong rồi Ít em reset
đô lecithin ID ạ Nếu có thì các bạn sẽ
phải điều hướng sang chàng người dùng
luôn nha Ngu dơ
Champagne
thôi axit ở đây và chắc này à
Hôm nay anh có bạn sẽ được hưởng sao cho
người dùng luôn nhớ bây giờ ạ đề năng
suất các bạn nhớ vụ đăng xuất hôm trước
đó em chỉ là
nó nó sẽ đâu
Em out sao đây thì nó sẽ xóa xin đi đúng
không ạ Khả năng suất này sẽ xóa đi này
tôi vào đăng nhập khi mấy ông thấy ạ lại
quay trở lại trang này nhưng mà rõ ràng
là mấy ông nhớ vụ bảo tôi vừa lưu lại
trong quốc kỳ tất cả có remember rồi cái
làm chỉ là nếu có cốc kia rồi cái mình
sẽ phải đăng nhập với tư cách của người
này rồi đua nói đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ
làm như thế nào
ở đây mình sẽ kiểm tra đây If reset
thì mình sẽ lấy Cookie ở ra thôi sẽ đôla
coky chí này là sự quốc kỳ vừa nãy mình
remember không ạ Nhìn này nếu mà có nhớ
có nếu có tồn tại đó ông ạ thì mình sẽ
làm gì mình sẽ vừa rồi là mình lưu lại
đây
đi tắm tí nhé Có rồi Mình lưu lại ID của
người dùng trong cái cô kia nên mình chỉ
lấy lại ID người dùng đấy lại thông tin
của người dùng thông qua đi thôi mình sẽ
có cái nổi cơ sở liệu này
ăn mì con ếch này à
có ai Tôi sẽ đặt ID bằng đôla Coffee tạ
từ bờ này
các tổ lại đi này à
Ơ
sao lại kết quả ra à
I
Turn on high PR mình sẽ phải à
để lưu lại trong section như cũ ở Như
thế này có ích tại hay đi đấy và nêm
Ê
mày không có thể đẩy cái này nên làm
trước cái này cũng được
bởi vì
à vì tạo xong nữa mới ông có thể là kiểm
tra mà luôn sau đó điều hướng về như thế
này khá tiện ở như thế này nếu không sẽ
thấy lập tức đăng nhập vào thông qua
thông thông qua là kiểu có cục có Cookie
rồi nó sẽ đăng nhập hộ luôn các bạn và
năng suất ra à Bạn đăng nhập vào lại lập
tức là nó sẽ tăng lại sang bên người
dùng luôn Nhưng mà như tôi đã nói thế
thì ra thấy làm xong cái cốc kỳ đấy
Ẩm Thực ra là chị có hai thứ mình cần
lại sửa đây thứ nhất là trứng và đăng
xuất ra rồi thực ra bản chất là nhiều
tra năng suất ra nó sẽ xóa hút của ông
chứ không chuyện Ông đăng xuất ra rồi
ông là đăng nhập Ông ấy không cần đăng
nhập bạn nữa Thế hơi sai người cứ bắt
người dùng vì trải nghiệm người dùng
người ta tư duy đó là đăng xuất đã rồi
những làm chị ạ phải đăng nhập lại thì
mới được đăng mới mới được chứ không
chịu đăng xuất ra rồi Ra ngồi
oke cũng vẫn còn hiệu lực thì không cần
đăng nhập bởi vì Giả sử dạng nhựa Ông ra
ông ra nét hoang dùng mày cá nhân của
ông thôi ông cho ai đó dùng máy của ông
ông sẽ thường Ông nghĩ à Tôi đang xuất
ra rồi để mà bạn sẽ thằng kia không phải
vào máy tôi nóng sẽ không vào được tài
khoản của tôi đúng ạ bây giờ vào sử
trang đăng nhập đăng nhập lại như như cũ
thì được cả toàn quá đúng không ạ Thế
nên là ạ bây giờ đăng xuất phải xóa quốc
kỳ là một lần thứ 2 đó là cũ kỹ này như
tôi đã nói nó rất là không ổn theo kiểu
là nó lưu lại theo mã người dùng cái này
thì ra không tốt Bởi vì bây giờ tôi đổi
mã bằng hai ta sẽ đăng nhập được vào tài
khoản cái khác được ngọn Em thấy không
một ngờ đầu tiên tôi xử lý mới năng suất
lại nhé
Ừ mình đang xuất này thì mình cây thước
ra cái xóa Cookie Thật ra cũng dùng
Chính cái hàm setcookie thì mà xóa thôi
chị đơn giản như thế này nó sẽ là mình
sẽ đặt cho nó một cái giá trị có thể
luôn làm chị ở không không không có
không có hoặc à à Ông đặt ra giá trị gì
cũng được quan trọng Miễn là ông sẽ cho
thời gian và thời gian trong quá khứ
thận chứ thời gian nó là trừ một ngày
chắc chắn nó nó là ở thời gian là quá
khứ tại thử năng suất này và đăng nhập
lại này có thêm bé Ông thấy à nó sẽ bị
xóa cô kia ở đây là nó yêu cầu mình đăng
nhập lại nóng ạ Đây Ok không còn nữa
cái sân này vẫn còn vì cái season này nó
hơi bị dị mà ví khi mà ông mở Sistar nó
luôn muốn tạo một cái phiên chẳng qua
cái phia này nó không hiệu lực để ông
đăng nhập thôi chứ nó luôn tạo ông cái
khuyên rồi à
ở đây lấy cái vừa rồi chị Ngạn và ý ông
ở dùng cái hạt phim sex cu kia tôi thì
tôi chưa thử về đây đâu
Ừ Ừ để tôi thử phát nhạc được đấy đối
thủ nhé
a Mother season mình cứ đăng nhập đúng
không còn nhập từ trước
à à
ý nghĩa chữ thử về bây giờ
này
lưu lại sẵn đăng nhập này Ok Đăng nhập
thành công nó không ạ Bây giờ sang bên
ngu rồi này
một giờ chuyển VP Xin chào bạn lo lắng
giờ đang xuất thì thay vì cái này tôi ăn
xét đúng ạ thì mới ông dùng ăn xét tôi
tôi đang đoán là có thể được có dậy được
à À không không không có khi không được
có khi không được Tại sao vì cái hàn lấy
Cookie này lấy từ trên trình duyệt người
dùng về nhưng mà ham ăn xét lại như như
lý thuyết như lý thuyết thì làm ăn xét
này là xóa
anh xóa giá trị đấy ở trên server chứ
không phải xóa ở trên máy người dùng
thôi Tôi tôi thử pháp không được Tôi
nghĩ không đủ
ở Iceland
khi đó mẹ không theo
mình đoán chuẩn phết đó mày không phải
không đó là ăn xét lại tất cả nó xóa xóa
cái xóa cái đấy chứ giờ xóa cái vùng nhớ
nếu mà các bạn học bên máy tính rồi thì
cái này bản chất là biến bất kỳ mạng gì
đó nó lưu lại nó lưu lại bộ nhớ ở trên
gọi là địa chỉ vùng nhớ ở trên trên con
server để không ạ Cái tên biến bản chất
nó địa chỉ địa chỉ vùng nhớ thì cái này
là xóa trên server để không ạ Nó sẽ cho
đến cái địa chỉ đấy nó xóa con cái
Cookie này lưu trên máy khách hàng nhưng
để khám ăn xét mà nó không nghĩa gì cả
đúng
em nghe máy không phải chơi trò này
thế
nhưng đại khái Thế nếu không thấy là rõ
ràng buộc rồi cô kỳ tôi Nó là một tôi
đổi nó thành hai chị ba bốn gì đó thì nó
sẽ là kiểu nhảy sang tài khoản với khác
đúng ạ Tôi thử vào
xem tại tài khoản ông nào có đổi tên
khác bởi tôi nhớ ông nặng tên là Long vì
vậy Liên bây là đổi tên để mẹ cũng không
phân biệt được đâu thay đổi thưởng nha à
Ừ nếu kỹ năng bạn đấy cả hai ông kia đậu
xanh
Anh nghe rồi tranh thủ tán gái trong
trường ạ
à à
à
À đây Đúng rồi không sao tên ông đầu ở
Long nó mày không nhớ tên Đông đầu long
nhá ông hay ông 34 thì đều Long hacker
đúng không ạ Đây tôi đổi mã thành kiểu 2
hoặc 3 gió sẽ phải đội hình 52 cơm tôi
tôi lỡ ấn clear rồi ly oke bay luôn cốc
kỳ thôi rồi à không khó vẫn còn ok rồi
nó hay nhá nãy anh hai rồi Tôi nhớ Ấn gì
nhá những cái này
Ừ hình như thế
vụ tai nạn tra xem đúng mà
em toàn em nhỉ
Ừ Ok hai rồi hai vợ ngon Tôi đã đăng
nhập đây đó mấy ông thấy tôi vào sử nick
người khác rồi thế không ổn không ạ
Ô thế không buồn đâu mạnh bởi vì em nếu
mà Mấy ông lưu lại mã của người dùng mà
trong kia tôi đổi nó lại mã của người
khác thì ra là đăng nhập vào người khác
nóng ạ Thế bây giờ mình làm như thế nào
thì giờ mình sẽ phải có cơ chế đó là
mình sẽ phải sinh ra cái đoạn cái đoạn
đoạn Mã gì đó mà người dùng không đoán
được nó gọi là có kèn đấy ạ nghĩa người
dùng không đoán được và phải mỗi người
dùng được nhưng phải có một cái Token
khác nhau đúng không ạ
ở mỗi người dùng phải to cao khác nhau
không thể dùng một tóc em nó tất cả mọi
người dùng được nó không ạ thì cái việc
mỗi người dùng một thói qen đó chính là
sinh ra ở trong chính cái bảng này mình
sẽ tạo mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ thêm một
cột Nữa của Token sau đó hai mình sẽ lưu
lại mỗi người dùng một ke như thế
Một này
Ừ nhưng mà đương nhiên là bây giờ thì ra
có nhược điểm là bây giờ là nếu không
thấy là tất cả người dùng của tôi đang
đều à
Đang đều không có to kèn không ạ
em nghe Bây giờ nếu mà nhập vào như này
nó sẽ báo lỗi
mày ông sẽ thấy báo lỗi bởi vì anh không
có giá trị 1 cố định ở đây vẫn được hả
Như ngoài thể giá trị nó biến giá trị rõ
mất rồi em mấy ông xe thì nó không được
nung như nó Dạ chị dẫn rồi lại chậm
thường nó sẽ phải báo lỗi ở đây cơ bởi
vì nó không được phép Mun chẳng qua đây
đang trôi rõ rồi Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
nhập vạc và sự ở đây bạn Long này sẽ có
tóc em đâu nha nếu không nên dùng nghĩa
là khi mà Mấy ông đăng ký và nó phải
xinh cho một cái tóc em rồi hoa à
đó chính xác là không phải đăng ký mà
khi mà ông Ấn vào cái nút
nút ghi nhớ mật khẩu
A ghi nhớ Đăng nhập đấy thì nó xinh A1
ông cái đó Token ba mấy ông sẽ phải dùng
cái tao Ken đấy thì mình không đăng nhập
vào cái biểu tôi sẽ làm cái đấy luôn bạn
kia hỏi phải cái Token full quyền của
Titan giới hạn quyền không ạ Thì bây giờ
mình đến cuối buổi thực là hôm nay mình
cũng đang định nói anh cuối buổi mình sẽ
xin phép nói về cái vụ phân quyền
có ai
Em à mình không đi đây ở đây có bài toán
phân quyền ông ạ Đây bàn tròn phân quyền
vấn đề môn của rất khó hiểu đây bởi vì
hôm trước cũng có bạn nói về việc là do
sự lại em có thêm nhiều loại người dùng
mà mỗi người dùng có một quyển khác nhau
thì em ghi thẳng ở trong code hả anh
không Mình sẽ phải lưu lại trong B về
sau mình còn dễ trình sửa nữa đã thì cái
việc đấy là mình mình sẽ phải thiết kế
đi tới bệnh đau tay như thế nào còn sẽ
rất lạ rất là rắc rối
anh nói chung là tí mình sẽ đề cập cho
các bạn hết mấy bộ lấy hi vọng các bạn
không đau đầu thôi còn mình rất là đau
đầu mình mình dậy thì các bạn Mình phải
cố nghĩ sao cho nó dễ nhất có thể các
bạn hiểu
Ờ thì đầu tiên thì mới quay lại nha Bây
giờ là mình đăng xuất ra rồi ok con nhờ
cái copy vừa rồi nó hết hiệu lực đúng
không ạ
Mình sẽ lại ấn lại đăng nhập Ok lần này
mình sẽ cần ghi nhớ khi nhớ đăng nhập và
nó sẽ sinh ra một cái tóc em cho cái
người dùng đấy và tóc em để sẽ lưu lại
trong Cookie người dùng và
Cookie đấy sẽ chỉ dùng để đăng nhập được
vào tài khoản kia thôi mà Có khi đấy nó
phải là một ngọn mã nó ngẫu nhiên không
ạ
đi đái mình sẽ là
ở đầu tiên là mình sẽ có mình sẽ lại
lòng hacker đúng ạ thì là không quan
trọng nữa tôi chỉ cần điền ngay chứ tao
đăng nhập được rồi này ăn cái người đó
nghiệp nhai thì là này mình ở đây mình à
khi bị xử lý sao đi anh ở đây khi mà ghi
nhớ này mình sẽ sinh ra một cái tóc em
ok này thường là tao kem này nó sẽ là
một cái chuỗi ngẫu nhiên nào đó thường
là tôi sẽ chơi trò thêm mà
thêm hát thêm kẹo Bon nó có mã hóa nó để
mà cho như tôi đã nói lập trình viên vào
xem cho kem người cũng khó mà nhớ và khó
mà giả được chóc em cũng khách hàng lập
trình viên và giả thói quen thấy Hà vào
được tài khoản khách hàng rồi không ổn
không ạ Cũng giống như mật khẩu ấy nóng
ạ
ý thì cái đoạn đấy thì thường là mẹ mấy
ông sẽ có khá nhiều cách để mà lại có
nhiều người dùng hạn thứ viện thôi thử
tra thôi là đúng sự Trinh P là em ạ đang
xảy ra nhiều cái
hôm nay nó sinh ra cái Hàn này cái Hà mà
gì
hả mày không mã hóa nào là chị đơn giản
là tạo ra một cái
một chuỗi ngẫu nhiên nào đó nhưng mà hàm
này có thể
a nay có thể thêm chủ để lắm chuyện nó
sẽ chắc chắn thêm tôi tôi nhớ có hàng
này rồi hàng này giống kiểu ID
cũng được hàng này được gặp khó ai đoán
được ok
Ừ
cái này fix lần đầu để làm chị ạ cậu kéo
án chị ở Đang đâu có thêm tính tố gì
không nóng để sống thêm u giờ được cho
bệnh chuyên nghiệp này em chu lại chưa
chán là nó sẽ sinh ra một cái đoạn đằng
sau thêm mấy cái cửa chấm chấm năm sau
để nó khó đoán hơn nữa đó thì đây chúng
ta có một cái các em rồi bây giờ tiếp
theo chúng ta sẽ phải update để Ok Đấy
và cho người dùng chị sẽ update customer
xét
ok bằng Token này à
à À như thế Lúc đầu to kem của tôi phải
là có thể luôn label mẹ ra lúc lúc đầu
thì có thể chống chỉ có khi mà người
dùng ấn vào ví nhờ đăng nhập thì mới
điện cho Ken mà nó hợp lý hơn và thế này
để tránh việc là khi mà Bây giờ tôi nợ
tôi tôi chưa Bây giờ tôi phải sửa file
đăng ký nữa bởi phan đăng ký rồi nó sẽ
lỗi vì nó đã còn Token đâu ông ạ que
đây có ai đi ông ạ Mình sẽ đây có ai đi
này mình sẽ ai đi bằng đôla X2 đi đây đi
cho rọ nó Ai sẽ ID này
các
bạn lại lại đi
mà đoạn mạng thế Ai đi bằng hai đi này à
Ê
mày như này
Sao Đỏ remember playing the
Ripper ưu dượng được thì các bạn đặt ở
đây sẽ lưu lại dạng to khe như thế này
đó
I felt mình sẽ
a ghi nhớ đăng nhập
Ừ ok Đăng nhập thành công các bạn sẽ
thấy ra cái bờ đây là sinh ra một cái
đoạn trỗ ngẫu nhiên như thế này đúng
không ạ Và
ở bên bây giờ mình quay lại bên đăng
nhập nhé
Mình đăng nhập này à
ở bên đăng nhập rồi chắc chắn nó sẽ bị
lỗi
em bị lỗi lại sao bởi vì À đây xem dòng
số 10 này
Khi dòng thứ 10 ở đây ở đây nó đang báo
lỗi vì lần này mình đang dùng ID lấy từ
grab được là sai bây giờ mình sẽ dùng
Chó Ken từ như thế này nó mới chuẩn này
à
Ừ cái này nằm hợp đấy ông ạ Cái cái cái
này vẫn có thể xảy ra trường hợp là hai
người dùng cùng chung một Token có thể
đương nhiên ở thật là nó hiếm mình nghĩ
là khó Có gì à cái cái Hàn này nó sinh
ra là unique hai cậu khó khó chung rồi
nhưng mà vẫn biết đâu nói khi mà sẽ lách
này nó sinh ra với Token trùng nhau nên
mấy ông chắc cho chắc cú hơn là bé ông
ấy hệ thứ nhất là mấy ông cho cài cho
Ken ở đây thêm một cột là unique này sau
đó chậm chị em mình không phải kiểm tra
xem là khi mà tạo ra như thế này ạ
update nó có bị lỗi không Nếu mà lỗi thì
bảo vệ sinh lại tao Ken Nếu phải chạy
phòng Đọc đoạn này một tí để sinh lại
tao kem này sẽ chuẩn cho kia nó không bị
trùng với người khác sau đó thì đoạn này
nữa Phải Limit muộn để chắc chắn là để
chắc chắn ra Kiều chỉ có một Token nó
được sinh ra thôi
ăn kẹo xuất ra mồ hôi
đấy nó hơi phức tạp thêm một tí không ạ
em nghe nói xong đại khái nói ở đây thật
ra vẫn vẫn còn trường hợp nhá ở đây là
sự khi lấy ra đây là lấy được mình khiếu
ở đây có thể có thể là
có thể người dùng nhập Linh ta tinh cái
to Ken vào cũng không thể cho người dùng
đăng nhập vào cái to cat linh tinh được
đóng ạ Mình sẽ kiểm tra ở đây đó là nếu
mà
à à
em bỏ ID vô đầu của toq em thực ra là nó
nửa hợp lý nữa không bởi vì ở thời ra là
mình không nên lấy ID từ mái tóc em mà
mình sẽ là mình mình mình mình sẽ ra
điều hòa
Từ từ tao Ken để xuất vào trong phải
nhập vào trong dp như thế này và lấy
thông tin từ trong BB ra chứ hỏi mình
lấy thông tin từ các em được nhưng mà
bạn nói thế Thật ra cũng có một cái hay
ở điểm khi mình nhìn theo Ken mình có
thể đoán được tao cái đấy của người dùng
nào cũng được Nhưng mà thường làm các
bạn thấy cái Token để mình có khen
Facebook của các em bất kỳ hàng nào cũng
làm gì có cái đoạn ạ Có Ken nàng đầu là
của một ai đâu đúng ạ
thường là mình hạn chế điều đấy
Ừ tại vì nó liên quan vọng mật Token nó
rất là bảo mật này ra là do Ken nó
thường ở không nên nhìn là tao kem này
để mà nhìn ra làm cái gì đó thông tin gì
đó
Có ai bán nó bỏ tao kem và trắng dùng mà
thực cái à cách để mà tránh chủng ổn
nhất thì mấy ông có thể chơi cho chắc cú
ngất đi thì mới ông có thể dùng hàng này
rồi thêm cả thời gian hiện tại vào nữa
ý là được đúng ạ
số mệnh Mỹ Thái chỉ cần thêm thời gian
hiện tại và giết rắn ơi theo kiểu mini
dây mấy ông sẽ gần như không mơ thể
trùng được không bao giờ ế chồng được
cái kiểu như thế
em chưa Bọn anh đi vào thời gian nó như
cả vì giá sự có ai mà bị lỗi có cây rồi
còn treo ạ nhìn phát ra đi của người đấy
là thực ra là dùng cho kem có thể vào
đường link rồi nhưng mà ý mới như thế
cho nó vẫn nhìn cả à
Ừ ok Nói chung là đại đoạn đoạn này thì
K mình phải xử lý thêm một bước đó là
mình à kiểm tra
55 bro mình kiểm tra xem là thì to Kem
này
ở đầu tiên mình cứ sửa đấy lại nha chỉnh
sửa đây này
Đây mình sẽ tạm Vứt cái to cái này ra
đây nhá
Bây giờ sửa mình sữa to cái này một cái
linh ta Tây ngày là sữa Tôi biết rồi cái
trang này sẽ kiểm tra to scan để mà đăng
nhập vào tôi Giả sử thôi thử là tộc họ
Kennedy là một Tôi nghĩ là tôi hệ sự có
khen là một để tôi sẽ ra được cái nick
51 chẳng hạn Đông ạ thì mình sẽ phải
mình sẽ kiểm tra ở đây đó là mình kiểm
tra xem ảnh khi mà salad này nó trả về
có bao nhiêu bạn ghi họ không có bản ghi
nào thì mình sẽ không làm gì cả thường
là không còn gì cả Không cần Không tỏa
lỗi Nhưng mình dùng luôn
từ nhỏ để người dùng vẫn đăng nhập vào
bình thường cái kiểu thế Mình sẽ mãi của
Ly nắm râu này bị sốt này
à à ạ sau đó đi
f5pro bằng bằng 1 thì mình mới làm cái
đoạn ở dưới hè thôi
t-ara
Còn không thì mình không làm gì cả mình
sẽ như này thôi thử nhé
Ừ tôi lẻ một này này tải trang
anh em yêu thế sáng ở hiện tượng này xảy
ra đây cả Không ạ Còn bây giờ tôi sẽ
nhét cái đoạn này vào
Lý Hải
ở đội bào ấn vào này phải lại tra này Đó
nó nghiệp thành công Ok nếu không hiểu
về cái đoạn Cookie và to scan cái thử
chưa
Khi bữa hôm nay cho ca thật ra mấy ông
thấy chưa ra cốc Hôm nay thì ra nó ngắn
hơn nhiều hoa cho ta giải thích nó cũng
khá là dài vì nó hơi bị nặng với lý
thuyết và nếu phải hiểu cơ chế của nó
khác biệt sân này Phân biệt nó này cái
áp dụng nó và và thức A cái này nó hơi
còn hơi nâng cao một tí Bởi vì tôi dậy
đó sinh viên Hồi trước của tôi ý thì nó
dễ hơn theo kiểu tôi cho sinh viên tôi
lưu lại mã vào trong cốc cốc kì luôn
Nhưng mà thực ra là tôi dậy cho mấy ông
không thể theo thế được vì em ấy ông như
thế mấy ông trang web bé ông dễ bị hack
không ạ
Ê tôi dậy là sinh viên tôi như thế được
Tại sao Vì tôi biết chắc chắn sinh viên
thôi cứ Dĩnh về học cái khóa thứ hai của
tôi khóa nâng cao để bọn nó sẽ phải biết
bảo mật hơn còn tôi dậy cho mấy ông bây
giờ phải dạy cho miếng bảo mật ngay từ
lúc đầu bởi vì tôi không Chắc được mấy
ông đã theo quả thứ hai của tôi mà Mấy
ông không theo Hòa được hai mà ông áp
dụng cốt này đi làm trong cái màu đỏ sau
miếu bị hack trứng biếng vậy thì tôi sao
tôi chết mất ông ạ thế nhưng tôi phải
dậy ôm những cái bảo mật
xe hơi nâng cao một tí
ngay từ bây giờ đấy rõ tôi dậy ông ấy
ông ấy hack cùng này thì cũng sẽ thấy
hơi bị choáng mà hơi bị nặng kiến thức
một tí nhưng mà hacker đối với bọn
hacker thì bọn nó mò mẫm cái này bọn nó
nghiện mình cái này phải dùng từ nghiện
chích mày cái ấm và bọn thích phá nữa
thì ra là mấy ông mà mấy chị học cơ bản
mà Mấy ông đã đi làm đã kiểu tao học cơ
bản nó có biết làm trang web rồi tớ
không học khóa nâng cao đâu rồi ông đi
làm trang web mà cốt kiểu như thế này
thì rất dễ bị hack ngã người không phải
quay kiện thôi chết tôi vừa dậy xong
thôi phải vừa dậy luôn cả bảo mật
Ồ không Tôi chưa cần phải dạy mày ông về
cái thư viện đấy đó mình cái sever gì đó
Tôi đang dạy mấy ông cũng tương đối rồi
mà đúng không ạ Thế này thì tao mày cũng
tránh tương đối rồi đấy
anh méo hiểu Mục đích và ý nghĩa chưa
đấy
chứ hồi mà tôi dậy ở sinh viên Tôi nói
tôi dậy cốt đoạn này ngắn lắm mấy cái
đoạn là không cần xử lý bọn nó còn chưa
biết spi nhé xin là cái gì cả Ừ nó chẳng
biết Token là cái gì luôn tôi không dậy
bọn nó cái tóc Ken đâu tôi dậy bọn nó
rất là đơn giản để Bởi vì tôi biết kiểu
gì cũng bọn nó cũng sẽ phải học từ đầu
đến cuối của tôi là cái gì sang khóa
nâng cao bảo tôi sẽ dạy Bỏ nâng cao về
hack cùng sau A
Ừ ok Nói chung nhất thì thế rồi ông ạ
thì bây giờ Nhân tiện bạn kia và lại hỏi
mình sẽ chia sẻ nốt một cái cũng đau đầu
nữa Hôm nay đau đầu có màu rất đau đầu
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nhảy sang bài toán
phân quyền và Lâu lâu không kém
Ừ
tự nhiên bệnh dithane ông kia là xe code
website buồn cười rồi à
ừ ừ
nhà mình có chia sẻ nhanh về hít vào
buổi cuối buổi hôm trước cơ mà mình sẽ
cách tướng đôi về cách sử dụng tool ký
thôi cầm bạn thể xem lại nhé
ở đây là quả on đấy Tôi không còn dạy
online ở chỗ khác đâu Đây là khóa online
đấy
ở đầu tiên để bài toán phân quyền thì
cái này là đây Đó là hình thức ngủ một
mức tương đối và anh đây cũng sẽ hiểu
chị nói quan vài cái thôi
ở đây thì giả sử ở đây nó sẽ có bạn anh
ấy luôn đặt ra câu họ trước không ạ Bạn
là sếp bạn toàn của toàn quyền này bạn
chuyển trưởng phòng chỉ có quyền của
nhân viên vọng mình bạn trưởng nhóm thì
sẽ có sẽ kiểu như này
vì nếu Giả sử bạn chỉ có một quyền hạn
mà có nhân này đối tượng vào lần này
quyền hạn thì bạn sẽ làm như thế nào
chẳng ạ và vì sau là sự có thêm nhiều
phòng ban nhiều bộ phận hơn chị sẽ có
quyền khác nhau thì sẽ thì sẽ làm như
thế nào Vân Vân có nhiều cái
ở đài thị thưởng xong rồi cẩn thận chế
phân quyền theo nhóm thì làm như thế nào
cho hạ thế
ở đầu tiên thì mày toán đơn giản nhất mà
tôi dậy tôi dậy cho mấy ông đang làm đồ
án đó phân quyền theo cấp bậc theo kiểu
chỉ có một cột cột cấp bậc như thế này
và cột này sẽ có thể lỗi xong bản khác
kiểu nghe cũng được
à à Không em đôi khi không Có nối xong
bạn khác ở một và to nhất hay đi rồi Bà
Thứ ba như thế này chẳng hạn như thế này
ưu điểm này dễ dàng cho người bắt đầu
lại đó ông ạ thì các bạn chỉ cần chết
tương đối đơn giản là kiểm tra xem em ạ
Cái kiểu người này có quyền một hai
quyển 2 những điểm thì nó sẽ nhược điểm
nó sẽ là kiểu Đây là sự nghiệp điểm này
không phải lúc nào nó cũng chỉ có mỗi
vài quyển như thế đôi khi ở giờ sự Thu
Ký có quyền đổi việc thế nhưng lại chẳng
hạn thì nó sẽ thuộc quyền của giám đốc
hay là gì đấy chẳng hạn thế về sau có và
nó khó làm phân quyền chi tiết
ở đài phân quyền chi tiết là nó sẽ kiểu
như thế nào nó phân quyền như tổ chức
năng như thế này để ví dụ là có toàn
quyền đọc này à Có toàn quyền hay là có
mỗi quyền đọc này hay Có mẫu Quyền truy
cập này còn mũ quyền sửa không cần xóa
này là sử như là hôm trước làm
Anh à Hôm trước làm trang web tin tức
chẳng hạn tin tức thì không trước mà tôi
dậy cho ông ấy Ông chỉ có đơn giản là có
admin mà Superman thức là kiểu nhân viên
và quản lý
đây đúng không ạ thì nhân viên ở sẽ có
quyền thêm và xem
đã sửa nhưng mà chị được sữa à Cái liên
quan bản thân ở nhà không có xóa ở Ngạn
nhưng mà quản lý trị có quyền thêm xem
và sửa và xóa luôn em ạ
Ừ cái kiểu thế mà ông sẽ thấy à Thằng
này nó sẽ ít hơn quyền hỏi một cấp chẳng
hạn cơ Thế thì phù hợp với việc là làm
hai kiểu tạo ra bảng lại bảo permission
như này mà bạn áp trên sau đó nối nối
người dùng từng người từng người dùng
nhé Nói đến cái quyển các thứ thứ phân
cấp như thế này tóm gọn lại nó sẽ là gồm
47 như hãy trả lại đó
cho tôi tôi không giải thích Mấy cái
bảng ở đâu Mấy ông thể tham khảo sau nhé
Thôi để đường link này mày ông tham khảo
này à
ý Thì cái này nó rất phù hợp với việc ưu
ưu điểm nó sẽ là gì
Ừ nếu anh xem ví dụ 2 cái từ từ sau nhé
tôi bỏ qua mấy đứa bạn này cứ điểm này
thì mới ông hoàn toàn thể làm chi tiết
được cho mỗi người dùng có quyền gì các
thứ thứ nhưng nhược điểm là cái này nó
nó ừ ừ
Ừ cái cái cái vừa rồi thấy vừa rồi nó
vẫn là nhóm nhá Nó vẫn giúp chứ không
phải từ người dùng đâu thì phải cho xem
Có ai đi permission
thế hả Đấy Đại vẫn từng người dùng rồi
Tại sao đây nhược điểm lại xem nhóm nhé
a a dunno cái trên một nhóm mà theo ấy
chị ra là một người dùng sẽ có hành động
các thứ thứ nhưng mà không không chia sẻ
theo cả một người dùng có thể một lúc
hai quyền được ra sự thư ký nó vừa là
thức ý nó vừa là quyền giám đốc Anh Thư
còn đây làm chị một người dùng chỉ có 1
lô thôi là một kiểu một chức vụ thôi còn
nếu là một người dùng có thể có nhiều
chức vụ Ví dụ ở sự như là trưởng phòng
trưởng phòng đi trưởng phòng vừa có
rô là trưởng vòng vừa có
Chức vụ của nhân viên nữa nghĩa một lúc
nó nó có thật hay chức vụ và hai chức vụ
để nó phải có 22 điều với môi trường
khác nhau
cho nên là cái đấy không phải thiết kế
được B nó có lằng nhằng hơn nữa và kết
luận ở đây kết luận ở đây đó là thực ra
là tạo ra nhiều DB như thế sao nấu về
nhau Thực ra nó rất là phức tạp Các bạn
thấy Riêng cái bảng này của anh đấy làm
để mô thôi Nhìn thấy bảo ở chung dài vãi
chưởng ông ạ Anh có bao nhiêu người dùng
ở mấy ông vệ sinh ra bởi nhiều như thế
này không đánh Index cái này mệt này sao
mày không có phải chết chung cái thôi
cái đoạn này Đột nhiên có rất nhiều thư
viện Bây giờ mày ông áp dụng Facebook
này mà có rất nhiều thư viện về
permission mấy ông làm được các thao tác
chỉnh sửa quyền nhanh rồi hay tự động
thêm quyền nhanh rồi nhưng mà đây là để
mà đi sâu hơn hiểu mình Ông muốn đi sâu
hơn và hiểu bản chất của một cái thư
viện này làm món gì với ông thì đọc qua
bài này và ví dụ rồi thấy nó rất là ạ ôi
ông Tom và giải thích này nữa thì chị
tôi cũng đau não à
thế này bởi vì cứ mỗi lần mỗi lần mà Mấy
ông kiểm tra có quyền xóa bài hay gì đó
không Mày không phải do người này bà nếu
không thấy cái cũng mệt không ạ Đấy như
thế này thì mới ông sẽ thấy cậu nó nó
thức cơ à Mình mà đánh Index cho nó rồi
và do voi được ra nó khá nhanh trong cái
queo nhưng mà đoạn này cũng về các bạn
nó sẽ là nó sẽ là kiểu phải phải sẽ rất
nhiều ấy không Mỗi lần vào một cái một
cái a b c ông cứ bấm nhầm cái đường Linh
nào đó là nó lại kiểm tra quyền ông ông
có quyền truy cập của cái đấy Không
nhưng mà như thế thì nó mới ổn phải bài
toán nó bảo mật bởi vì không cho người
dùng tự quyền xin sửa một cái gì đó nó
không ạ
Ừ tôi không dậy không mày không cái này
đâu Tôi không dậy không mấy ông cái này
ở đồ án Cơ bản thôi chị dậy yêu miếu có
quyền đăng nhập vào thôi nên bài toán
phân quyền tôi tạm bỏ đi nhé
Ừ Ok chưa
ở nhóm đâu hết rồi chán quá bỏ hết rồi
Ừ đúng rồi khóa này khóa đầu tiên và
cũng có thể là khóa cuối cùng có thể
thôi
Em không biết được về sau mày ông có dụ
dỗ kèo thôi không Tôi là con người à
không dễ bị bệnh hót nhưng mà tôi kiểu
đó
Ừ thôi mà thấy có cái gì đó làm cho hứng
lên là thuốc làm đấy à
anh không hiểu chắc chắn thôi không thể
Ông vừa nghe gái ông hiểu được cái này
nhưng mà lại khán thì mấy ông thấy cái
này khó không ạ nhưng mà cái này mới thì
tiêu đây nó nói tất cả mà nó là rất là
khó hiểu đúng ạ ạ
Ừ cái cái này thì đại khái nãy giờ mấy
ông chỉ cần đúc kết Kể như thế này đó em
chỉ là tôi dậy cho mấy ông đơn giản có
lý do của nó bởi vì đó đó và tôi dạy cho
mấy ông chỉ việc à à Kiểu phân hai hay
thứ nhất là phải phân ra thành kiểu 2
cấp ngoại và mỗi cấp nào thì làm được
ABC ghi thẳng vào trong cốt là hàng ngày
chỉ được truy cập và cái này thằng này
được phép truy cập bởi kia vào trong cốt
Còn mấy ông muốn làm cái kiểu đó
Ê thằng admin này sẽ chữa truy cập vào
cái bài đăng của nó đã thêm chị phép sửa
được đang mở thêm đã làm một cái thêm
khói đó ngoan
rồi kết hợp với việc là
thêm một hàng nữa thằng Duyệt bài của nó
chỉ phép Duyệt bài chứ nó không được
phép sửa bài không phép thêm bài nào ạ
thì nó lại phải lưu lại trong B1 cái cấp
độ nữa nói khó hơn cho mấy ông muốn càng
làm chi tiết thì cốt của ông càng rối và
càng khó hơn thế thôi ngoại và dp các
bạn phải lưu lại những cái Yêu người nữa
họ sẽ khó hơn
Ừ
nếu mà đi làm mấy ông
ở miệng phải làm những cái khó như thế
thì người ta mới chuyển ông ấy không ạ
đương nhiên là mấy ông không phải lo
việc là buổi em mới đi làm em gặp này
xem chết không chuyện đấy bởi vì em mới
đi làm về ông không được động vào những
cái liên hoan đi database đâu mà không
sẽ chỉ làm những cái tính năng thêm sữa
xóa rất đơn giản thôi Còn nếu mà nhưng
mà về sau phải xác định lườn đó mấy ông
muốn nếu mà mức lương nào không ạ Mấy
ông vẫn muốn mình ở mức lương mới đi làm
à Không ạ Mấy ông muốn mình ở mức lương
cao hơn không ạ mức lương cao hơn ở bên
ngành lập trình viên này nó không phải
ông làm nhiều năm kinh nghiệm thì sẽ lên
đâu mà nó là ông làm và làm được kẹo
phải tự nâng trình bản thân mình lên đấy
thì mức lương nó mới lên
ở đâu ạ Nó sẽ có gọi là sẽ có đợt review
dùng từ đợt review đợt
review lương nó sẽ kiểm tra lại trình độ
của ông xem là cái trình độ của ông đang
đến cái ngưỡng nào rồi thì nóng mới nó
mới quyết định tăng lương cho ông ngoại
nghe nhiều ông kieu Han kìa mấy cái mấy
Tôi còn biết mấy ông Thạch sư chứ Đợt
review về trình độ của ông lúc vào mới
vào với cái lúc sau một năm thì có trình
độ ông vẫn thế với ông bị lười Hải Vân
ông suốt ngày Ông chị cốt những ngày
phân ông đã Ông biết ông không đọc thêm
tài liệu tôi không nghiên cứu thêm ấy
sau một năm Nếu không vẫn chỉ biết xem
thêm sữa Xóa Thằng ạ thì được review nó
sạch sau đó thì mấy ông cay cú với ông
sẽ nghỉ việc đấy lý do mà cái ngành này
nó luôn hót như thế của việc
Ẩm Thực ra lập trình viên giỏi theo kiểu
ngày ngày nghiên cứu thì ít mà ông kiểu
cứ nghĩ rằng là ngày ngày dễ rồi nhảy
vào nhiều tiền nhiều
à Tôi đang chia sẻ thật đấy tôi không hề
dụ dỗ mấy ông theo ngành công nghệ không
tin lắm
Ừ cái đấy Đang chị sạch da thật tôi
không sợ mấy ông cướp việc của tôi nên
tôi thì mày Ông Táo cũng không đưa đến
đến lượt Nếu cứ việc đâu vì nhiều việc
lắm Nếu mà
Ừ tôi vẫn sẽ dạy mày ông Lập trình để
mày không hiểu qua toàn bộ Tôi bảo là
học khóa này không phải để mấy ông thành
lập trình viên ông ạ quá sau mình mấy
ông mới thành lập trình viên được khóa
này chỉ để mấy ông hiểu qua về lập trình
viên làm được những gì nếu không làm
được như lập trình viên hay không Nếu
không có phù hợp với lập trình viên hay
không đúng ạ nhấn mạnh về những người
tiêu trị của về khóa học này rồi đấy ạ ạ
ạ
à à
Ẩm Thực tập An thực tập Người ta vẽ vợ
chồng gì đó mơ mộng và vứt cho mày phải
quên dữ liệu
anh nói chung là thằng theo ngày này thì
ra mấy ông làm đầy đủ những cái mà Mấy
ông đã học thì thực ra nó vẫn sẽ chỉnh
mức lương như thế người ta sẽ không
không đuổi được với ông đâu nhưng mà
người ta sẽ không tăng lương ông đâu bởi
vì à
anh Bởi vì ông có học có
có cái gì đó hơn đâu nó khác hàng khác
như điểm đấy mưa Khởi đầu có thể ạ tương
đối cao so nhàng các nhưng nó vẫn sẽ chỉ
dậm chân tại chỗ tại đấy thôi nên nhiều
mình nghỉ việc chứ là nhiều ông nhảy
việc sao không lấy được con thất nghiệp
thế ngành này nó vẫn
thiếu thiếu người không ạ mà toàn thiếu
người
có bao nhiêu bao nhiêu nhà Tuyển dụng
đều nhắn tin kiểu toàn bằng mấy cái kiểu
ở mức lương có thể đến 2.000 đô là bao
nhiêu đâu rồi Thậm chí ông chỉ cần giới
thiệu về ông bà biết làm một tí vào
trong công ty kia ông đấy mà nhận được
nhận việc ông được 15 triệu luôn hai 20
triệu luôn cả bạn đấy nó còn vợ nó còn
hấp dẫn như thế đúng không ạ Em Vẫn
thiếu người bởi vì sao Vì vẻ đẹp
cài
đặt trình viên mình
anh vẫn còn đang bị kiểu chạy theo à
chứ không phải chạy theo đam mê mà chạy
theo kiểu dạng ạ về tiền bạc nhiều hơn
không ạ
ở tuổi tôi đam mê nhiều hơn là tiền thì
phải ra được treo được
anh chia sẻ mức lương thực tế mức lương
thực tế thì tôi từng nói rồi đó là khi
mà Mấy ông một con mấy đi làm ở nhận mới
đi làm thì người ta lại chửi cho phụ cấp
thôi Có công ty nào hợp hấp dẫn một tí
thì thì phụ cấp tận 1 đến 3 triệu Còn
công ty nào một kiểu sáp kiểu bèo thì sẽ
cho 500 thôi
500 có khi a vẫn còn tương đối có công
ty 200 rồi thế
khi họ vẫn sẽ vụ hỗ trợ cho các bạn về
thiết bị cấp cho xứ ít công ty nào không
bây giờ không chuẩn bị cho mẹ ông Thiết
bị ốm
à Nếu nghe mẹ ông sẽ phải trao trả lại
thiết bị người ta Nếu không nhỉ
ạ sau đó thì hiện khi ông nhận được việc
thì lương lên đến 78 triệu Hoàng 15 thí
nghiệm với ông sẽ 78 triệu sau đó đi chị
235235 thí nghiệm thi ạ Đấy là theo kẹo
ông càng làm
làm và ông làm được dần những cái tính
năng dần dần dần lên chứ không phải ạ
Không không phải là vẫn tiếp tục những
cái những cái tính năng cơ bản thì ông
sẽ tăng dần lên chỉ cần ở 35 là ông thể
lên đến 15 triệu 3 5 1 5 triệu ở Quảng
Bình thường để đấy ông theo kiểu là là
con người bình thường nhé Còn nếu mà ông
theo cậu đã thân đồng những cái thứ thứ
thì 35 lên đến 20 triệu lấy 40 triệu
chuyện vẫn là bình thường Em vẫn ở dơ
bình thường ở trong cái ngày này kiểu gì
tôi quen rất nhiều người còn lên đến
bây giờ tính toàn nghìn đô mà không ạ
Nhưng trước khi nộp có rồi
anh
giống như à em về thảo ở trong Triều
Tiên này được trả 1 Bitcoin này
nghe nghe nhỏ vậy một Bitcoin á Không
không không đến nỗi một Bitcoin nhưng mà
chào biết coi nghe thấy đù Xấu mà
à à
đã bao lâu nữa hết khóa bao lâu nữa chả
tấm ai bá đạo nữa thôi
điều hòa sau rồi sẽ lập trình nâng cao
cho tôi lúc này tôi không hi vọng đông
người như này đâu bởi vì đông người như
thế này thì à
gì nó cũng có cái ngại cho tôi à Ăn một
vì khi nâng cao rồi à Tôi sẽ mở mở máy
không quá nhiều lắm đấy ông ạ học hỏi từ
rất nhiều nguồn này cũng như thoải mái
cốt bằng nhiều ngôn ngữ này xong rồi
dùng như thư viện rất hư không mấy ông
mà hỏi thôi mấy cái đấy thôi Chẳng biết
trả lời ông nghĩa nào
về lúc này tựa họ cũng dễ mà nhiều hơn
như tội sẽ dậy đầy đủ mà ông cách làm
Nói chung là định hướng là mấy ông nhiều
hơn
à à
Ừ đúng rồi mình sẽ vừa mình dùng mình
phải dậy trước MV xe opel đã Sau đó mình
sang reserved e-movie xe ouat song Thực
ra các bạn từ đấy mà các bạn nhảy sang
ngôn ngữ khác cũng được gặp kiểu ta thấy
rõ nét vai thon tùy ngoa I
cho Bơ cũng có nhiều công ty nước ngoài
tuyển được sinh viên Việt Nam mà tôi có
mấy ông chỉ cần đọc tài liệu tiếng Anh
cơ mà
Ừ đúng rồi đi cà phê mốt đấy à
ấn
độ hôm nay tại miền đây thôi nhỉ bạn
thắc mắc nó thử xem còn mà họ nốt em có
gì không ạ
Mỹ Tâm Cốt tập 10 năm nữa thì sẽ làm gì
đấy Thực ra là
tôi tôi cũng chẳng hi vọng của tôi sẽ có
10 năm kinh nghiệm thường là tôi bảo rồi
nếu không phải từ ra lúc đấy Mấy ông
không đủ người ông kiểu đầu óc có thể
tính toán nhiều rồi mình không còn minh
mẫn mà ngồi học hỏi thêm công nghệ nữa
thường là mấy ông sẽ là lý do cậu là
định hướng rồi cũng như cậu
Chuyên về xử lý bài toán này tập toán
các thứ hoa cà Nếu có mấy ông không quên
cảm thực hành những cái đấy Nếu không
thể quay về đi dạy này lấy vốn mở một
cái gì đó ở quán net hả nhãn tôi đang
định mở quán cà phê này không ạ khi nghe
các vì sao rồi sẽ đi dạy tôi giọng nói
à à
Chỉ có tôi sẽ nói qua về 2 tf2 xe đấy
thôi còn nó có được đấy
Ừ thôi tra Bộ không ai em Thế thôi nha
Chào bạn nhé
Ừ ok
ừ ừ